Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. The year was 1975, and on British television millions of viewers were about to discover the secret behind one of the greatest mysteries of all. Across the country, families watched open-mouthed with excitement as an intrepid band of investigators revealed the truth. Centuries earlier, an alien
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。每周收听独家加更节目、无广告收听、抢先体验系列节目，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的 rest》。要获取加更节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。那是 1975 年，在英国电视上，数百万观众即将揭开史上最大谜团之一背后的秘密。全国各地的家庭都惊得目瞪口呆，兴奋地看着一群勇敢的调查人员揭示真相。几个世纪前，一个外星
spaceship had crashed into the freezing waters of the Scottish Highlands, a spacecraft belonging to a shape-shifting race called the Zygons. And now, in the age of Gerald Ford, Leonid Brezhnev, Harold Wilson and Karen Carpenter, the Zygons were preparing to unleash their ultimate weapon, a terrifying creature known as the Skarason, or as we would call it, the Loch Ness Monster. So Tom Holland, that was Doctor Who, Terror of the Zygons. And let's be honest, it's no more implausible than some other explanations of the Loch Ness Monster. And what did that description come from? Is it from a... I read that myself.
飞船坠入了苏格兰高地冰冷的水域，那是一艘属于被称为“齐贡人”（Zygons）的变形种族的飞船。现在，在杰拉尔德·福特、列昂尼德·勃列日涅夫、哈罗德·威尔逊和卡伦·卡彭特的时代，齐贡人正准备释放他们的终极武器——一种名为“斯卡拉森”（Skarason）的可怕生物，或者正如我们所称的，尼斯湖水怪。那么，汤姆·霍兰德，那是《神秘博士》里的《齐贡人的恐怖》。老实说，这并不比关于尼斯湖水怪的其他一些解释更离谱。这段描述是从哪来的？是来自……我自己读过这个。
Did you? In which book? I read it just now. Did you? Do you not write bespoke introductions for episodes of The Rest is History? No, normally I rip them out of books. I'm very, very impressed. So you didn't write about this in any of your landmark histories of 1970s Britain?
是吗？在哪本书里？我刚才读的。是吗？你难道不为《历史的 rest》的单集撰写量身定制的引言吗？不，通常我都是从书里撕下来的。我真的，非常印象深刻。所以你没有在任何关于 20世纪 70年代英国的里程碑式历史著作中写过这个吗？
Although I could have done, because actually what awakens the Skarrison and the Zygons in that Doctor Who story from 1975 is North Sea oil, is the efforts to get North Sea oil. So it's very, very timely. Right. So, I mean, this takes us immediately to the point of what we're talking about today, which is obviously the Loch Ness Monster. And you may may be wondering why are we talking about the loch ness monster in a history podcast because we're not crypto zoologists um or anything along that line dominic you're well known for your love of science and natural history of course everybody knows i love science but but that very specific mid-70s context for the lo Ness Monster shows, I think, why we're covering it. It's a historical phenomenon, isn't it?
虽然我本可以写，因为实际上在 1975 年那一集的《神秘博士》中唤醒斯卡拉森和齐贡人的，正是北海石油，是为了开采北海石油的努力。所以这非常、非常契合时事。没错。我的意思是，这直接把我们带到了我们今天讨论的主题，很明显就是尼斯湖水怪。你可能在想，为什么我们要在历史播客里讨论尼斯湖水怪？因为我们不是密码动物学家，或者诸如此类的人。多米尼克，你一向以热爱科学和自然历史而闻名，当然，人人都知道我热爱科学，但关于尼斯湖水怪那种非常具体的 70 年代中期背景，我认为恰恰说明了我们为什么要报道它。这是一个历史现象，对吧？
It is a historical phenomenon. Because the 70s, when I was growing up, the Loch Ness Monster was a very, very vivid part of my mental imagination. Yeah. And we'll come to why later on i wonder if you had the same usborne book that i did which was a book of mysteries that had um the loch ness monster bigfoot the yeti i did all of you know and it's actually what these are these are interesting comparisons because they they're very revealing about why people become interested at a particular moment yeah in these kinds of phenomena.
这确实是一个历史现象。因为在 70 年代我成长的时候，尼斯湖水怪是我脑海中非常、非常生动的一部分。是的。我们稍后会讲到原因。我想知道你是不是和我看过同一本 Usborne 图书，那是一本关于神秘事物的书，里面有尼斯湖水怪、大脚怪、雪人……我确实看过，你知道的。实际上，这些是非常有趣的比较，因为它们非常清楚地揭示了为什么人们会在某个特定时刻对这类现象产生兴趣。
Well, I did have that, but I also had another book, which was, and I can still, if I shut my eyes, I can visualize it. Absolutely. It was by a man called Tim Dinsdale, who again may reappear in our narrative. But on the cover, it was a purple, so it was a kind of twilight setting the lock um urquhart castle the famous ruined backdrop to so many uh illustrations of loch ness and there was a kind of plesiosaur so a long-necked aquatic reptile from the mesozoic rearing up its neck um and i i came across it just as I was emerging from my dinosaur obsession. But I so wanted it to be real.
嗯，我确实看过那本，但我还看过另一本书，而且我依然——如果我闭上眼睛，我还能把它可视化。绝对是的。那是一本由一个叫蒂姆·丁斯代尔（Tim Dinsdale）的人写的书，他在我们的故事中可能还会再次出现。但封面上是紫色的，所以那是一种暮色调的湖面——厄克特城堡（Urquhart Castle），那是许多关于尼斯湖的插图背后的著名废墟背景，上面有一只类似蛇颈龙的生物，也就是中生代的长颈水生爬行动物，正在昂起脖子。而我遇到这本书时，正是我刚刚走出恐龙痴迷期的时候。但我太渴望它是真的了。
I so wanted Nessie to be real. And I think lots of other people did, particularly in the 70s. I think they did. They still do, I think, Tom. And I think that sense of yearning, that sense of kind of desperation to believe that this had existed i think is a really interesting but tom also there are people who have uh who are very keen for it not to exist not least um members of the scottish government who have recently been publishing advice we shall come to this because they have very strong views about um the popular culture of the loch ness monster don't they and indeed have been encouraging been encouraging Scottish schoolchildren to delve into this issue.
我太渴望尼斯湖水怪是真的了。我想其他人也一样，尤其是在 70 年代。我想他们确实如此。我认为他们现在依然如此，汤姆。而且我认为那种渴望的感觉，那种急切地想要相信它曾经存在的感觉，真的非常有趣。不过汤姆，还有一些人非常希望它不存在，其中绝不乏苏格兰政府成员，他们最近一直在发布建议——我们待会儿会谈到这一点，因为他们对尼斯湖水怪的流行文化有着非常强烈的看法，不是吗？事实上，他们一直在鼓励苏格兰学童深入研究这个问题。
Or have they? Well, we'll come to this. Or have they? Don't tell me this is yet another bit of fake, rest is history, fake news. That would be terrible. Well, the account I read was in the Daily Mail. And the Daily Mail, again, will play a very key part in this.
是吗？好吧，我们待会儿会讲到这个。真的是这样吗？别告诉我这又是《历史的 rest》的又一条假新闻。那可太糟糕了。好吧，我看到的报道是在《每日邮报》上。而《每日邮报》在这个故事中也将扮演非常关键的角色。
So Britain's best loved newspaper. So for those people who don't know, because I know we have a lot of Australians, lots of Americans, Belgians, Danes and so on who listen to this podcast. Tom, where is Loch Ness? OK, so what I would say, first of all, is that Loch Ness is not just a British phenomenon, that Loch Ness has a kind of global resonance. So we make no apologies for dealing with this subject. And it has featured in large numbers of Hollywood films,
所以这是英国最受欢迎的报纸。因此，对于那些不知道的人——因为我知道有很多澳大利亚人、美国人、比利时人、丹麦人等等在听这个播客。汤姆，尼斯湖在哪里？好的，首先我想说的是，尼斯湖不仅仅是一个英国现象，尼斯湖具有一种全球性的共鸣。所以我们探讨这个主题无需道歉。它曾在大量的好莱坞电影中出现过，
all kinds of stuff. So the Loch Ness Monster is up there. You mentioned Bigfoot. You mentioned the Yeti. It's one of the kind of the big crypto zooids, I think. You're trying not to say the big beasts, aren't you? The big beasts. The big beasts. So the backdrop to this the setting of loch ness um it's the largest body of fresh water
各种各样的作品。所以尼斯湖水怪名列前茅。你提到了大脚怪。你提到了雪人。我认为它是那些大型神秘动物之一。你正极力避免说“大野兽”，对吧？大野兽。大野兽。所以这背后的背景，尼斯湖的环境——它是英国和爱尔兰最大的淡水水体，
in britain and ireland and it's basically very very long and very very thin yes if you imagine um the map of scotland uh there is a kind of it's called the great glen it's this great kind of valley that goes roughly kind of about 45 degrees doesn't it yeah um from the south up towards the north so it's from roughly fort william to inverness isn't it yes uh to uh and it's that the the lock itself is uh it's about a mile across. It's about 23, 24 miles long, and it's very, very deep. So at its deepest stretches, it's deeper than the North Sea is between Scotland and Norway, and it's very, very cloudy,
而且基本上非常、非常长，也非常、非常窄。是的，如果你想象一下苏格兰的地图，有一种——它被称为大峡谷（Great Glen），这是一个巨大的山谷，大致呈 45 度角延伸，对吧？是的，从南面向北延伸，所以大致是从威廉堡（Fort William）到因弗内斯（Inverness），对吧？是的，一直到——湖本身大约有一英里宽。大约有 23、24 英里长，而且非常、非常深。所以在它最深的地段，比苏格兰和挪威之间的北海还要深，而且它非常、非常浑浊，
so very, very difficult to see what lurks beneath the depths, which is also obviously very important and for a long long time it was very very isolated the road that most people go along where castle features is on the um the western side and the the train on the eastern side is much harder to negotiate there is now a road and, we'll perhaps talk about how the road comes to be there. But basically, it's a very deep, very long, relatively speaking, certainly by British standards, isolated stretch of water. And that really is the context that Britain is a very crowded island. So the likelihood that there would be an unknown monster anywhere. Yeah.
所以很难看清深水底下潜藏着什么，这也显然非常重要。在很长一段时间里，它非常、非常偏远。大多数人走的这条路——厄克特城堡就坐落在西侧——而东侧的铁路则更难通行。现在有一条路了，我们也许会讨论这条路是如何建成的。但基本上，这是一个非常深、非常长（相对而言，当然以英国标准来看）、与世隔绝的水域。这确实就是背景：英国是一个非常拥挤的岛屿。因此，在任何地方存在一个未知怪物的可能性……是的。
Well, the Surrey Puma, of course, there were sightings of pumas in Surrey. Again, it was never tracked down. Beast of Bodmin. If you remember the Beast of Bodmin,
嗯，萨里美洲狮（Surrey Puma），当然，萨里郡曾有美洲狮的目击报告。同样，它也从未被追踪到。博德明野兽（Beast of Bodmin）。如果你还记得博德明野兽的话，
but monsters are more plausible, aren't they? The further you are away, you are away from the great kind of Southeastern metropolis. Well, so if you think of the other one, the Yeti is in the Himalayalayas they're very isolated bigfoot is sasquatch is kind of the the forests of um northwest america yeah so again very isolated i know the highlands are quite remote but they're still they're not that remote so it's it's extraordinary that the monster comes to have this purchase. It does.
但怪物似乎更可信一些，对吧？离东南部的大都市越远，就越可信。所以，如果你想想另一个例子，雪人远在喜马拉雅山，它们非常偏远；大脚怪，也就是萨斯奎奇（Sasquatch），存在于北美西北部的森林里。所以同样非常偏远。我知道高地相当偏远，但它们也没有那么偏远。因此，这个怪物最终能获得如此高的知名度，是非常非凡的。确实如此。
And I suppose the question that that asks is why. And perhaps the best way to look at that is we've got a question from Tom, Boat History, Golding. Roughly what date is the first recorded mention of a monster in Loch Ness? Well, you have the answer to this, don't you? It's pure Tom Holland territory, this. Well, it have the answer to this, don't you? It's pure Tom Holland territory, this. Well, it's provided. The answer was provided on Twitter by none other than the great Fergal Sharkey.
我想由此引发的问题是：为什么？也许最好的切入方式是，我们收到了来自汤姆（Boat History, Golding）的一个问题：关于尼斯湖出现怪物的最早文字记录大约是在什么日期？好吧，你一定知道答案吧？这完全是汤姆·霍兰德的领域。好吧，你知道答案吧？这完全是汤姆·霍兰德的领域。答案是由大名鼎鼎的费尔加·沙基（Fergal Sharkey）在 Twitter 上提供的。
So who's that, Tom? Lead singer of the Undertones. And, of course, the Lorax. People in Britain will know him as the Lorax of the chalk streams. He's been leading a campaign against the despoliation of our chalk streams by predatory water companies. He's one of your walking pals, isn't he? He took me for a walk along the River Ver, which is a river that gave its name to Verilinium.
汤姆，那是谁？The Undertones 乐队的主唱。当然，还有“环保树精”（The Lorax）。英国人会把他当作白垩溪流的“环保树精”。他一直在领导一场反对掠夺性水务公司破坏我们白垩溪流的运动。他是你的散步伙伴之一，对吧？他带我沿韦尔河（River Ver）散步，韦尔河是 Verilinium 得名的那条河。
All right, let's get back to Loch Ness. Let's get back to Loch Ness. When is the first mention of the Loch Ness monster? Tom? Well, as I was saying, Fergal gave us the answer to this. He said that he was answering on August the 23rd, and he said that yesterday, so in other words, August 22nd, was the 1457th anniversary of the first sighting of Nessie
好吧，让我们回到尼斯湖。让我们回到尼斯湖。尼斯湖水怪最早是什么时候被提及的？汤姆？嗯，正如我所说，费尔加给了我们答案。他说他是在 8 月 23 日回复的，他说昨天——换句话说就是 8 月 22 日——是圣高隆（St. Columba）首次目击尼斯湖水怪的 1457 周年纪念日。
by St. Columba, a famous Irish monk. What's this five about the year 565 we're talking about 65 by 55 so that is supposedly the first dating of a monster in loch ness and saint columbia you a fay with saint columbia i i there's i i think about saint columbia most days tom um but just remind me who who he was well he's an actually i Well, actually, remind the- I know, obviously, but remind the- Of course you do. He is an absolutely- He's a top early medieval saint. He's from Ireland. Columba means the dove. In Irish, he's called Colmcille. I hope I pronounced that right.
我们说的是公元 565 年左右……不对，是 565 年还是 55 年？所以这据说是尼斯湖怪物的最早目击记录，而圣高隆——你对圣高隆很熟悉吗？我——我几乎每天都在想圣高隆，汤姆。但请提醒我一下，他是谁？好吧，他其实是一个——好吧，其实提醒一下——我知道，当然，但提醒一下——你当然知道。他绝对是一个——他是一位顶级的中世纪早期圣人。他来自爱尔兰。Columba 意思是鸽子。在爱尔兰语中，他被称为 Colmcille。希望我发音准确。
Any Irish listeners, let me know if I haven't. It means the dove of the church. And he, like so many of these kind of holy men from Ireland, is of an aristocratic background who then gives it up to lead a highly ascetic life. And it's that kind of process of self-abnegation that gives him his sense of power. But he brilliantly, according to tradition, that again is, as you say, one of those restless history facts that isn't a fact, but he gets into trouble because he gets embroiled in
如果有爱尔兰听众，如果我没读准请告诉我。它的意思是“教会之鸽”。和许多这种爱尔兰圣人一样，他拥有贵族背景，后来为了过上高度苦行Một的生活而放弃了这一切。正是这种自我克制的过程赋予了他一种力量感。但根据传统，他又巧妙地——这再次证明了，正如你所说，这是那些并非事实的“历史的 rest”趣闻之一——他陷入了麻烦，因为他卷入了
the first ever battle fought over copyright. So there's a Welsh saint called Saint Finian who has a Psalter and Columba borrows the Psalter and makes a copy of it, and then says that he wants to keep the copy of it. And Finian says that he should have it back because he owns the original salter and therefore every copy properly belongs to him and so they take it to the high king of ireland who says to every cow belongs her calf therefore to every book belongs its copy so in other words that you know he's not a fan of book selling no irish law is very restrictive very very restrictive um and columbia is very cross about this because he has to hand the uh the copy of the salter over and so he he gets all his um his extensive and very very uh well-armed family to raise a rebellion against
历史上第一场因版权而引发的战争。有个叫圣芬尼安（Saint Finian）的威尔士圣人有一本诗篇（Psalter），高隆借了这本诗篇并抄写了一份，然后说他想保留这份抄本。芬尼安说他应该把抄本还回来，因为他拥有原本的诗篇，因此每一份抄本自然都属于他。于是他们把这闹到爱尔兰至高王那里，至高王说：“每头母牛都有它的小牛，因此每本书都有它的抄本。”换句话说，你知道的，他不赞成图书售卖。不，爱尔兰法律非常严苛，非常、非常严苛。高隆对此非常生气，因为他不得不交出诗篇的抄本，于是他动员了他那庞大且全副武装的家族，发动了一场反对
the king and there's a big battle so it's the first battle over a copyright issue. And Columba basically, it's not looking... If you're a holy man, this isn't the kind of behavior that you want. So he leaves Ireland. So this is a story that's very, very late, written about a thousand years after Columbaus lived but i think it does draw on a tradition that perhaps columbus aristocratic background leads to him um being embroiled in dynastic politics in ireland in a way that is incommensurate with his status as a man of the church and also uh as you may remember when we talked about patrick um it's a big irish thing among the saints that you go into a kind of exile that you you go on a pilgrimage abroad so Saint Brendan going off to discover America is one Saint Columbanus going
国王的叛乱，爆发了一场大战。所以这是关于版权争议的第一场战斗。高隆基本上——这看起来不太好。如果你是个圣人，这不是你想要的行为。所以他离开了爱尔兰。这是一个非常晚近的故事，写于高隆生活的 ABOUT 一千年后。但我认为它确实借鉴了一个传统，即高隆的贵族背景或许导致他卷入了爱尔兰的王朝政治，这与他作为教会中人的身份格格不入。而且，正如你可能记得我们谈论圣帕特里克时所说的那样，圣人们有一个爱尔兰传统，那就是进行某种流亡，去国外朝圣。
to the the continent is another and Columba he just pops across the sea to uh to Scotland and he gets given the island of Iona and it's from Iona that he then goes up the Great Glen along Loch Ness up towards Fortriou which people from who listened to our episode on Macbeth may remember it's kind of Pictish kingdom around where Inverness is so that kind of area of Scotland and the Pictish king is called Bride and he's very interested in what Columba has to say he doesn't convert to Christianity but he allows Columba to come in and Columba has various bust up with the Druids who are hanging around with Bride. But the other thing that he has a bust up with is a mysterious monster that inhabits Loch Ness.
所以圣布伦丹（Saint Brendan）出海发现美洲是一个例子，圣高隆奴（Saint Columbanus）前往欧洲大陆是另一个例子。高隆只是漂洋过海来到了苏格兰，人们把爱奥那岛（Iona）赐给了他。正是在爱奥那岛，他沿着大峡谷穿过尼斯湖，一直走到弗特里乌（Fortriu）。听过我们关于《麦克白》那一集的听众可能还记得，那是因弗内斯周边的一个皮克特王国，也就是苏格兰的那个区域。皮克特国王名叫布里德（Bridei），他对高隆要说的话很感兴趣。他没有皈依基督教，但允许高隆进入，高隆与那些跟布里德混在一起的德鲁伊（Druids）发生了一系列冲突。但他的另一场冲突是与一个栖息在尼斯湖中的神秘怪物。
And the story is, and this comes from an account of Columba's life that was written about a century after he did this. So 565, he's crossing the River Ness and he sees this person being buried. And he asked, you know, what's been going on? And the people who are burying this body say that the man had been swimming, that he'd been seized and that he had been most savagely devoured by a water beast. And some people go out, they and and uh beat the the monster off um too late the guy is dead but they they manage to get the body back out of the monster's jaws and they bring him back and they they're burying him so columbia hearing this decides something needs to be done and so he tells one of his followers to go out and get a boat that is floating out in the in the lock and
故事是这样的，这来自于一篇在高隆事迹发生大约一个世纪后写成的关于他生平的记载。所以在 565 年，他正在穿过尼斯河，看到有人在下葬。他问发生了什么事，那些正在埋葬尸体的人说，这个人当时在游泳，被一只水兽抓住并极其残忍地吞食了。有些人出动去把怪物赶走——虽然太迟了，这人已经死了，但他们设法从怪物嘴里把尸体夺了回来，并带了回来进行安葬。高隆听到这个消息，决定必须采取行动。于是他叫一个追随者去弄一艘漂浮在湖上的小船。
uh one of his followers does this, goes out, but the monster is still hungry, so comes hurtling towards the man who's swimming out, and he's screaming and saying, ah, I'm about to be eaten. But Columba makes the sign of the cross, and... I'm reading it in here, yeah. You will go no further.
他的一个追随者照做了，划了出去。但怪物依然饥肠辘辘，于是朝正游向水中的那个人猛冲过来，那个人尖叫着说：“啊，我要被吃掉了！”但高隆划了十字，然后……我在这里读着呢，是的。你休想再往前一步。
Do not touch the man. Turn back speedily. He said it in that voice, Tom. He said it exactly like that. So the beast does go back as if pulled back by ropes. It says here, I'm just reading the saint's life. And the guy, you know, everybody's delighted. And they say, hurrah, hurrah.
休想碰这个人。火速回去！他就是用那种语气说的，汤姆。他就是那样说的。于是这头野兽真的退回去了，就像被绳子拉回去一样。这里写着，我正在读圣人的生平。然后那个人——每个人都很高兴。他们说，万岁，万岁！
And so these people crucially are pagans, aren't they? So they see this and they say columbus must have access to this tremendous heavenly power isn't this splendid hurrah for god and jesus christ pretty much yes um and this is in the context of um well we we talked about tolkien last week so we talked about Beowulf. Beowulf's mother is a fearsome monster who inhabits a watery domain. So that sense of lakes and locks as being places where the spawn of Cain might live, monsters bred of the first murderer, is a tradition that is not just Germanic,
所以这些人关键是异教徒，对吧？他们看到这一幕，然后说高隆一定拥有这种强大的天神之力。这难道不精彩吗？为了上帝和耶稣基督万岁！差不多就是这样。嗯，这是在……背景下发生的，我们上周谈到了托尔金，所以我们谈到了《贝奥武夫》。贝奥武夫的母亲是一个栖息在水域中的可怕怪物。因此，湖泊和湖沼被视为该隐的后代、由第一个杀人犯孕育的怪物居住的地方，这种传统不仅存在于日耳曼文化中，
but clearly part of... Yeah, well, here's my question for you, Tom. As you're a man, I mean, if there's anybody I know who enjoys saints' lives, medieval saints' lives, you are that man. This would strike me as an absolutely classic saints' life formulaic device, rather than a genuine zoological topographical
而且显然也是……是的，汤姆，我的问题是这样的：作为一个精通圣徒传记——中世纪圣徒传记——的人，据我所知，你就是这样的人。在我看来，这绝对是一个非常经典的圣徒传记公式化套路，而不是真正的动物学和地形学
description so in other words if you read saint's lives beasts are always lurking in rivers uh the saint is is using his powers to sort of cast them out or or whatever i mean especially you know what is this sixth century i mean this is an age when when people are writing saints lives they always follow set formulae and there's absolutely surely no reason to believe that saint columba genuinely confronted a creature of this kind in the river i'm not sure i'm not sure about that i i mean i don't think he did confront the lotless monster because i don't think the lotless monster existed but maybe some things that make it more specific i don't actually think that saints go around confronting aquatic monsters all that much i mean okay but
描述。换句话说，如果你读圣徒传记，野兽总是潜伏在河流中，圣人则是利用自己的力量把它们驱逐出去或者别的什么。尤其是，你知道的，这是公元 6 世纪吗？这是一个人们在撰写圣徒传记时总是遵循固定公式的时代，绝对没有任何理由相信圣·高隆真的在河里遇到过这种生物。我不太确定，我对此存疑。我的意思是，我不认为他真的遇到了尼斯湖水怪，因为我不认为尼斯湖水怪存在。但也许有些细节让它变得更具体了。其实我不认为圣人们整天都在跟水怪搏斗。我是说，好吧，
doesn't do it aiden doesn't do it uh all these other saints don't i bet you i bet you i can find examples of saints who confront well malevolent amphibians but if we're comparing it to beowulf i mean it's more a kind of heroic thing it's kind of a warrior thing and it may be a i don't know maybe it's a reflection of the fact that columbra is of of warrior stock perhaps um okay yeah i don't know but just one thing to throw into the mix is that um the picts famously didn't write so we we have no writings by the picts but they were very very keen on um sculpting they say absolutely wonderful sculptures and they were very keen on sculpting animals
阿丹（Aidan）没有这样做，其他所有圣人也都没有这样做。我敢打赌，我一定能找到圣人与恶意两栖动物搏斗的例子。但如果我们把它和《贝奥武夫》相比，这更像是一种英雄行为，一种武士行为，这可能是一个——我不知道，这也许反映了这样一个事实：高隆出身于武士阶层，也许……好吧，是的，我不知道。不过有一点可以补充的是，皮克特人出了名地不写文字，所以我们没有皮克特人的文字记录，但他们非常热衷于
and all the animals are instantly recognizable but there is one very there's one uh aberration uh one animal that doesn't seem to be anything recognizable at all and it's this kind of strange beast with um it's either a very long snout or a beak something so a bit like a kind of crocodile's jaws and flippers so maybe that's what inspired the story uh slightly clutching at stores there but but am i not right in saying though tom that okay so columb St. Columba has this confrontation with this beast, but then it kind of goes quiet. I mean, in the 10th century, in the 12th century,
雕刻。他们制作了绝对精彩的雕刻作品，并且非常喜欢雕刻动物。所有的动物都一眼就能辨认出来，但有一个非常——有一个反常的动物，一个看起来完全无法辨认的动物。它是一种奇怪的野兽，有着长长的吻部或喙，有点像鳄鱼的下巴和鳍。所以也许这就是故事灵感来源？稍微有点牵强附会，但——我难道说错了吗，汤姆？好吧，圣·高隆与这只野兽发生了冲突，但后来它就沉寂下去了。我的意思是，在 10 世纪、12 世纪，
people aren't saying, gosh, remember there's that monster up at Loch Ness. I mean, no one is talking about the Loch Ness monster at all. So I'm quoting here from an excellent book that was written seven years ago by Gareth Williams, A Monstrous Commotion, The Mysteries of Loch Ness,ous commotion the mysteries of loch ness which uh goes through the history of all these sightings and he quotes um a reference in 1520 yeah a chronicler saying that the monster of loch ness is still unkilled which is very could be you know intriguing person could be a bandit captain or something. It could be. Yes, it could be. Or a wolf or, you know, some horrible bear.
人们并没有说：“天哪，还记得尼斯湖上的那个怪物吗？”我的意思是，根本没有人谈论尼斯湖水怪。所以我在这里引用一本七年前加雷斯·威廉姆斯（Gareth Williams）写的优秀书籍——《一场骇人的骚动：尼斯湖的谜团》（A Monstrous Commotion, The Mysteries of Loch Ness），书中梳理了所有这些目击事件的历史，他引用了 1520 年的一处记载，
Do they have bears? I mean, maybe they didn't. But, you know, that doesn't mean that's pretty vague. It is. It is. Your searching scepticism is yet again puncturing the balloons of hope. But I think it reflects the fact that, as we said, that Loch Ness is very, very remote and isolated. And that again, of course, going back to Columba is a key part of it because the whole thing about saints is that they go to very remote places.
一个编年史家说尼斯湖的怪物仍然没有被杀死。这可能——你知道的——是个耐人寻味的人，可能是个强盗头子什么的。很有可能。是的，可能是。或者是一只狼，或者（你知道的）某种可怕的熊。它们有熊吗？我的意思是，也许没有。但是，这并不意味着——这太含糊了。确实如此。你那探索性的怀疑精神又一次刺破了希望的气球。但我认为这反映了这样一个事实：正如我们所说，尼斯湖非常、非常偏远和与世隔绝。而且，再次回到高隆，这也是其中的一个关键部分，因为圣人们的所有核心特征就是他们会去非常偏远的地方。
That's the mark of a holy man, whether it's a desert or whatever. So in a sense, going to the shores of a remote loch is part of that tradition. And basically people are not going there until the 18th century. So we mentioned how it's the western side that is much more easily approachable. The eastern side, very, very hard to get along because the kind of sheer cliffs and everything. And the guy who changes that is a man whose name must forever live in infamy, General Wade. Well, I think you're being a bit harsh on General Wade. Yes, because General Wade is an 18th century general, isn't he?
那是圣人的标志，无论是沙漠还是别的什么地方。所以在某种程度上，去到一个偏远湖泊的岸边就是那种传统的一部分。基本上，直到 18 世纪人们才开始去那里。所以我们提到过西侧更容易接近，而东侧由于陡峭的悬崖等原因非常难以通行。改变这一现状的人是一个其名字注定遗臭万年的人——韦德将军（General Wade）。好吧，我觉得你对韦德将军有点太严厉了。是的，因为韦德将军是 18 世纪的将军，对吧？
And he's tasked with building these military roads. In the aftermath of the Union of England and Scotland, there's been the Jacobite uprising. And the Hanoverians are very keen to bring Scotland, to bring the north of Scotland into the orbit of the newly formed union. And military roads are meant to enable people to march quickly if there's another Jacobite rising or something. So I guess, is Generalade badly regarded in scotland to this day tom yes so general so so wade basically creates the infrastructure in the highlands and he joins up all these forts that have been built to essentially kind of keep control of the highlands um he builds a lot of roads and
他的任务是修建这些军事道路。在英格兰和苏格兰合并之后，爆发了詹姆斯党起义。汉诺威王朝非常渴望将苏格兰、将苏格兰北部纳入新成立的联邦的势力范围。修建军事道路是为了让军队能够在发生另一次詹姆斯党起义或类似事件时迅速行军。所以我想，至今韦德将军在苏格兰名声很差吗，汤姆？是的，所以韦德基本上在高地上创建了基础设施，他把所有这些为了控制高地而修建的堡垒连接起来，
one of the roads that he builds kind of blasting out you know cliffs and so on so that he can construct this path is along the eastern side of Loch Ness. And I think, I mean, I think, I guess if you're a Jacobite, you're not very keen on this. But I think if you're wanting to get from one side of Scotland to the other, then it's great. So there's this famous verse written about about him if you had seen this road before it was made you would lift up your hands and bless general wade is that by some sort of mcgonagall
他修建了大量道路。他修建的其中一条道路——通过炸毁悬崖等方式来建造这条小路——是沿着尼斯湖东侧修建的。我想，如果你是个詹姆斯党人，你大概不会喜欢这个。但如果你想从苏格兰的一边走到另一边，那真是太棒了。所以有一首关于他的著名诗句：“如果你在修好之前见过这条路，你就会举起双手祝福韦德将军。”那是某种麦戈尼格尔（McGonagall）式的人物写的吗？罗伯特·伯恩斯？我觉得不是。不。所以他修建了他的道路，他还招募了大量的高地团。
figure robert burns i don't think so um no and and so he's he so he's building his roads he also he recruits lots of highland regiments. And basically, these become the Black Watch. So this is a time when the Highlanders are seen by the British military authorities as a threat. But Wade is the guy who starts saying, well, actually, they're such good fighters, maybe we can get them into the British Army. So he's starting that. But then the reason why his name is to forever live in infamy is that Bonnie Prince Charlie's uprising happens and Wade is in Newcastle and Bonnie Prince Charlie goes on the other side. So he goes past Carlisle and gets all the way down to Derby before doing his retreat, going back to Culloden and so on, and escaping disguised as a French maid. Wade is so annoyed about this, the fact that he was unable to get from Newcastle over to Carlisle, that he decides to build another road linking Newcastle to Carlisle.
基本上，这些高地团成为了黑卫士兵团（Black Watch）。所以这是一个高地人被英国军方视为威胁的时代。但韦德是那个开始说“其实他们很会打仗，也许我们可以把他们招进英国军队”的人。所以他开始了这一切。但为什么他的名字注定遗臭万年呢？因为“邦尼·普林斯·查理”（Bonnie Prince Charlie）的起义爆发了，而韦德当时在纽卡斯尔，邦尼·普林斯·查理则走了另一条路。所以他越过卡莱尔，一直南下到德比，然后才撤退，返回卡洛登（Culloden）等战役，并伪装成法国女仆逃脱。韦德对此感到非常恼火——因为他无法从纽卡斯尔赶到卡莱尔——以至于他决定再修建一条连接纽卡斯尔和卡莱尔的道路。
And he's in such a hurry that he looks around for convenient stone that could serve him as the foundations for this military road and what do you think the convenient stone is that he uses don't tell me he he he built a road out of hadrian's wall he does so general wade is the guy who basically destroys hadrian's wall and the reason why the only stretches of hadrian's Wall that survive are in areas where rugged cliffs and so on is because General Wade didn't want to go there. Still, I bet he got a bloody good road out of it, I imagine. Yeah, fine. So that's why not a fan. Not a fan.
他太匆忙了，以至于四处寻找可以作为这条军事道路基石的便捷石料。你猜他用的便捷石料是什么？别告诉我他用哈德良长城（Hadrian's Wall）修了一条路！他还真这么干了。所以韦德将军基本上就是摧毁哈德良长城的人。哈德良长城之所以只在那些悬崖峭壁等地区幸存下来，是因为韦德将军不想去那里。不过，我敢打赌他用它修出了一条非常棒的路，我猜。好吧，挺好的。这就是为什么大家不喜欢他。不喜欢他。
Anyway, so Wade builds this road, and it's known as Wade's Road. And that opens up. People can now start going down Loch Ness on both sides and basically um it's from this point on that you start to get kind of mentioned so there are there are there are people um there are workmen who as they're building the road who report seeing two leviathans so two giant creatures they and they think they might be whales. Yeah. Then through the 19th century, occasional reports,
无论如何，韦德修建了这条路，它被称为韦德之路（Wade's Road）。这就开放了交通。人们现在可以开始从两侧沿着尼斯湖前行，基本上——从这个时候起，你开始看到一些记载——有工人在修路时报告说看到了两个利维坦（leviathans），也就是两个巨大的生物，他们认为那可能是鲸鱼。是的。然后到了 19 世纪，偶尔会有报告，
but I mean these reports are nothing. They're insubstantial, will-o'-the-wisp reports of exactly the kind that you would get all over the place. People who've actually probably seen a big fish, a seal a wave a wave a boat that you know it's a stormy day and they're yeah they're drunk or or they're just romantically inclined and they think they've seen something gosh we saw something in the water and probably their account of seeing something would be utterly lost and forgotten were it not for the fact that people started looking back and sort of you know delving through the archives to find every fleeting reference yes i but i think also it's a bit like you know a snowball going down a mountainside that it picks up velocity as it gathers weight
但我的意思是这些报告算不上什么。它们是空洞的、虚无缥缈的报告，正是你在各个地方都会听到的那种。人们可能真的看到了一条大鱼、一只海豹、一个海浪、一艘船——你知道的，那是一个暴风雨的日子，他们喝醉了，或者只是满脑子浪漫幻想，以为自己看到了什么。“天哪，我们在水里看到了东西！”如果没有后人回头翻阅档案来寻找每一个转瞬即逝的提及的话，他们声称看到东西的说法可能早就完全迷失并被遗忘了。是的，但我认为这也就像一个雪球滚下山坡，随着重量增加而加速，
so 1888 there is a guy who who's clearly been drinking too much whiskey who claims to have seen a monster like a large salamander. So that makes it into the newspaper. I mean, a salamander, that's not... That's like a zygon, isn't it? Yeah, that's not the conventional image of the Loch Ness monster, is it, a salamander? No, no, it's not. And by the end of the 19th century,
所以在 1888 年，有一个明显喝了太多威士忌的家伙声称看到了一只像大蝾螈一样的怪物。这上了报纸。我的意思是，蝾螈？那可不是——那就像个齐贡人，对吧？是的，那可不是尼斯湖水怪的传统形象，对吧？蝾螈？不，不是的。到 19 世纪末，
it's become sufficiently well-known that people in America, in newspapers, can write about it, about there being a monster in Loch Ness. And it's kind of part of the Highland mythology. It's part of the romantic evocation, I guess, of the Highlands as a wilderness. I would guess no more than, say, the story of black dogs in Norfolk or something like that. If you're interested in folklore, perhaps you're aware of it. But most people, it's barely intruding. And then that changes with the 30s. And in the 30s, I think you could legitimately talk about Nessie mania. So before we get to the 30s, Tom, can I just interrupt you a second?
它已经变得足够知名，以至于美国报纸上的人都可以写关于它的文章，说尼斯湖里有一个怪物。这算是高地神话的一部分。我想，这可以说是对高地作为荒野的一种浪漫唤醒。我猜这不会比诺福克郡的黑狗传说之类的事情多多少。如果你对民俗感兴趣，也许你知道它。但对大多数人来说，它几乎毫无存在感。然后这种情况在 30 年代发生了改变。在 30 年代，我认为你可以合情合理地称之为“尼斯湖水怪狂热”（Nessie mania）。所以在我们进入 30 年代之前，汤姆，我能打断你一下吗？
Because am I not right in thinking that the top necromancer, Alistair Crowley, he was involved with Loch Ness in some way. So for those people who don't know, he lived at the kind of turn of the 20th century. He was sort of Mr. Black Magic, the occult. He was the guy who popularized the occult. And I'm very happy to say, Tom, he's the third person in recent months to have appeared on this podcast who went to my old school. Did he?
因为我没记错的话，顶尖的黑魔法师阿利斯特·克劳利（Aleister Crowley）曾以某种方式与尼斯湖扯上过关系。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，他生活在 20 世纪之交。他可以说是黑魔法先生、神秘学代表。他是那个将神秘学大众化的人。我很荣幸地宣布，汤姆，他是近几个月来出现在这个播客中的第三个曾就读我母校的人。是吗？
Alistair Crowley went to your school? He did. So he joins James Jesus Angleton, demented CIA counterintelligence chief and top wardrobe purveyor C.S. Lewis as fellow old Malvernians like me. But they weren't. God, imagine C.S. Lewis and Alistair Crowley together. They must have been. I think there were different generations, to be fair.
阿利斯特·克劳利去了你的学校？是的。所以他与詹姆斯·杰克逊·安格尔顿（James Jesus Angleton，疯狂的中情局反情报主管）以及顶级衣橱供应商 C·S·刘易斯（C.S. Lewis）一起，成为了像我这样的老马尔文人（Old Malvernian）。但他们并没有——天哪，想象一下 C·S·刘易斯和阿利斯特·克劳利在一起。他们一定……我觉得公平地说，他们是不同世代的。
They weren't in the same rugger team. No, no, no. They didn't share a dorm. So Alistair Crowley, he lived near the log, didn't he? He wore a kilt and sort of pretended to be a laird. Yes, yes. But didn't he put up signs, or I've seen from your notes, he put up signs warning people about the Kalu Mavlik.
他们没有在同一个橄榄球队。不，不，不。他们没有共用一个宿舍。所以阿利斯特·克劳利，他住在湖附近，对吧？他穿苏格兰短裙，假装自己是个庄园主。是的，是的。但是他没有竖起标牌——或者我从你的笔记里看到，他竖起了警告人们注意“卡卢·马夫里克”（Kalu Mavlik）的标牌。
Yeah. He basically invented a monster to keep people off his land. We didn't even say it was a monster. He never said what the Kalu Mavlik was. He just put the signs up. And people became so terrified of him that they wouldn't go on his land we didn't even say it was a monster he never he never said what this calum avlik was he just put the signs up and people became so terrified of him that they wouldn't go on his land so it obviously worked he claims that he invented the lotness monsters i see well he did yes he did subsequently but but this is drawing on the on the reputation that he was already getting as a man of deep wickedness who summoned up demons and devils and so on yeah um so i think i again i don't think that that i mean once the loch ness monsters become famous then then crowley comes in and says
是的。他基本上凭空捏造了一个怪物来阻止人们进入他的土地。我们甚至没说那是个怪物。他从来没说过卡卢·马夫里克是什么。他只是竖起了标牌。人们对他的恐惧如此之深，以至于根本不敢踏上他的土地。我们甚至没说那是个怪物，他从来没说过卡卢·马夫里克是什么，他只是竖起了标牌，人们对他的恐惧如此之深，以至于根本不敢踏上他的土地。所以这显然起作用了。他声称自己发明了尼斯湖水怪——我明白了，好吧，他确实这么说过——随后——但这是在借用他作为一个被认为能召唤恶魔和魔鬼的邪恶之人的名声。是的，所以我认为——再次强调，我不认为这——我的意思是，一旦尼斯湖水怪出名了，克劳利就会跳出来说：“是的，这都是我干的。”但我不认为这是促成这一切的因素之一。因此，究竟是什么促成了这一切，就变得极其有趣。我想我们该休息一下了。我想当我们回来时，我们应该看看 30 年代发生了什么，尼斯湖水怪狂热，为什么会发生，以及之后的余波。我希望我在说这句话时不会剧透：
yes it was all me but i again i don't think that that is part of what's feeding into it and so the question of what does feed into it therefore becomes incredibly interesting and i think that what we should do i think we should take a break now and I think when we come back we should look at what happened in the 30s Nessie mania why it might have happened and then the aftershocks of that I hope I'm not going to spoil it for people when I say
我相信世界上最优秀的报纸之一很可能已经演变出来了，我说的对吗，汤姆？你说得对。休息过后，加入我们去寻找一份报纸。会是哪一份呢？我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
I believe one of the world's finest newspapers may well have been evolved am I right Tom? you are right join us to find a paper after the break. Which could it be? I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝演艺圈八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想无广告收听、获取加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票，
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。现在，令人无比兴奋的是，顶尖动物学先驱、探险家、研究员汤姆·霍兰德正准备解开尼斯湖水怪之谜。不，我没有。所以，汤姆，我们已经到了 20 世纪 30 年代。是的，你有的。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, very excitingly, top zoological pioneer, explorer, researcher, Tom Holland is poised to solve the mystery of the Loch Ness Monster. No, I'm not. So, Tom, we've reached the 1930s. Yeah, you are.
我们已经到了 20 世纪 30 年代。你声称 30 年代掌握着这个谜团的关键。好吧，具体是 1933 年。是的。好吧，1933 年。一切都在 1933 年爆发，你会发现一系列层出不穷的怪物目击事件。有趣的是，其中的各种元素
We've reached the 1930s. You claim that the 1930s has the key to the mystery. Well, it's 1933 specifically. Yes. Okay, 1933. Everything kicks off in 1933, and you get this cascading sequence of sightings of the monster. And what's interesting is the way that the various elements of it
变得对我们越来越熟悉。所以在某种程度上，我们所有人脑海中的怪物形象，当你看到所有这些不同的报告时，你会发现它正在你面前逐渐凝聚成型。所以第一个报告来自——一个名叫阿尔迪·麦凯（Aldie Mackay）的女人，她和丈夫正开车沿着厄克特城堡那一侧行驶，也就是西侧，是的，西侧。这得到了当地的《因弗内斯信使报》（Inverness Courier）的报道。这就是《因弗内斯信使报》当时的报道方式。引用阿尔迪·麦凯的话：
become more and more recognizable to us. So in a sense, the image of the monster that we all have, you can see it coalescing in front of you when you look at all these various reports so the first one is um a woman called aldi mckay who is driving with her husband down the castle urquhart side um and this is the western side yeah and the western side uh and this gets reported um by the local the courier in inverness and this this is how the Inverness courier reports it. So quoting Aldi Mackay,
这个生物在水中嬉戏，翻滚扑腾了整整一分钟，它的身体像一头鲸鱼，水花飞溅，翻腾得就像一口沸腾的大锅。然而不久之后，它便在一团沸腾的泡沫中消失了。两位旁观者都承认，整件事透着一种诡异，
the creature disported itself, rolling and plunging for fully a minute, its body resembling that of a whale and the water cascading and churning like a simmering cauldron. Soon, however, it disappeared in a boiling mass of foam. Both onlookers confessed that there was something uncanny about the whole thing,
因为他们意识到这里没有寻常的深水居民，因为除了其巨大的身形之外，这头野兽在进行最后一次下潜时激起的水波，大得足以媲美一艘路过的轮船。哇，
for they realized that here was no ordinary denizen of the depths because apart from its enormous size the beast in taking the final plunge sent out waves that were big enough to have been caused by a passing steamer wow which perhaps begs the question of whether whether it was caused by passing steamer yeah i think the passing steamer reference there is uh is is disturbing to me to be honest yes so people are steaming on the lock at this point tom are they they are the lock is becoming a place of pleasure i suppose so i'm not entirely okay with uh with with lock nest the history of the tourist board of yeah yeah but it's not but but Dominic it's not it's not tourists so um because there's not you know there's the story of the monster
这也许引出了一个问题：那浪到底是不是路过的轮船引起的？是的，我认为那里提到的路过的轮船对我来说有点——令人困扰，老实说。是的，所以当时人们已经在湖上开船了，对吧，汤姆？是的，湖泊正在变成一个供人游乐的地方，我想。我其实不太能接受——尼斯湖旅游局的历史……是的，但这并不是——但是，多米尼克，这不是——因为没有什么——怪物的故事没有任何知名度，除了大片的水域之外也没什么可看的。但你有一些人——他们基本上是可以信任的，因为他们要么是脚踏实地的水手、熟悉水域的人。所以有一个水政官员叫亚历克斯·坎贝尔（Alex Campbell），在整个夏天期间——我们待会儿会谈到他——他看到了一个……他为这个故事引入了一个至关重要的元素。但在那之前，你还有更多的驾车者，一次又一次，这全都是关于沿湖开车的驾车者。这是一对英国游客，乔治·斯派瑟（George Spicer）和他的妻子。关于他们，有趣的是他们不是在湖里看到它的，而是在他们面前横穿马路时看到的。我的意思是，这——
hasn't got any currency and there's not a lot else to see apart from a large expanse of water but you have um you have people who can basically be trusted because they are either sort of the earth water men people who are familiar with the waters so there's um uh there's there's a water bailiff uh called alex campbell who over the course of the summer will come to him in a minute sees a he introduces a crucial element to the story but before that you also have more motorists and again and again it's all about motorists going down the line of the lot and these are two english tourists george spicer and his wife and what's interesting about them is that they don't see it in the lock they see it crossing the road in front of them i mean this the
没有货币，除了大片的水域之外也没什么可看的，但你有一些基本上可以信任的人，因为他们要么是脚踏实地的人，要么是熟悉水域的水上居民，所以有一个叫亚历克斯·坎贝尔的水警长，他会在夏天晚些时候过来，他引入了故事的一个关键元素，但在此之前，你还有更多的驾车者，一次又一次，这全都是关于沿着湖岸开车的驾车者，他们是两个英国游客乔治·斯派塞和他的妻子，关于他们有趣的是，他们不是在湖里看到它的，而是在他们面前过马路时看到的，我是说这个
description is it's terrifying they're driving along the road aren't they july 1933 so they're clearly on their summer holiday and they see a large creature, 25 feet long. A long, wavy, narrow neck, slightly thicker than an elephant's trunk. And George Spicer describes it as the nearest approach to a dragon or prehistoric animal that I have ever seen in my life. Which may be saying nothing because presumably he'd never seen a dragon or a prehistoric he says it had an animal it had an animal in its mouth and a body that's fairly big with a high back where webbed feet he can't say if it had a tail because it moved so rapidly when we got to the spot it had probably disappeared into the log and actually when you read up on them they don't sound like fraudsters mr and mrs george biser from golders green because he works at a gentleman's
描述说：这太吓人了，他们正在路上开车，对吧？1933年7月，所以他们显然是在过暑假，然后他们看到一个巨大的生物，有25英尺长。长、弯曲、狭窄的脖子，比大象鼻子稍微粗一点。乔治·斯派塞把它描述为“我一生中见过的最接近龙或史前动物的东西”。这可能等于没说，因为据推测他以前从没见过龙或史前动物。他说它嘴里含着一只动物，身体相当大，背部很高，有蹼足，由于它移动太快，他说不清它有没有尾巴。当我们到达那个地点时，它可能已经钻进木头里了。事实上，当你了解他们时，来自戈尔德斯格林（Golders Green）的乔治·斯派塞夫妇听起来并不像骗子，因为他在伦敦西区的一家绅士
tailors in the west end he's the director yeah um yeah uh and so that again you know this seems a reputable witness a gentleman's tailor he's not going to be lying is he but the gentleman's tailor so this is really the of all the descriptions of the monster this is really the, of all the descriptions of the monster, this is probably the most important, would you say, Tom? Because it's the one that really establishes the... Well, it blends with Alex Campbell, the water bailiff, because it's Alex Campbell. He describes seeing a monster with a long wavy neck. And it's Alex Campbell who first suggests that it is like a plesiosaur. And the plesiosaur is the long-necked Jurassic creature with the flippers. But George Spicer is unusual. I mean, it's worth emphasising this point. His description is so unusual because he describes the monster not in the water.
裁缝店工作，他是董事，对，嗯，对，呃。所以这再次表明，你懂的，这似乎是一个信誉良好的目击者，一个绅士的裁缝，他不会撒谎，对吧？但是绅士裁缝——所以这真的是，在关于怪物的所有的描述中，这真的是……在关于怪物的所有的描述中，这可能是最重要的，你会这么说吗，汤姆？因为正是这个描述真正确立了……嗯，它与水警长亚历克斯·坎贝尔（Alex Campbell）的说法不谋而合，因为就是亚历克斯·坎贝尔。他描述说看到了一只长着长长弯曲脖子的怪物。正是亚历克斯·坎贝尔首先提出它就像蛇颈龙。蛇颈龙是一种长着长脖子、带有鳍肢的侏罗纪生物。但乔治·斯派塞很不同寻常。我是说，值得强调这一点。他的描述是如此不同寻常，因为他描述怪物时，它不在水里。
So the monster is wandering out on the road. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. A description that has never been repeated. So the monster was wandering on the road. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. A description that has never been repeated. So nobody else has ever seen the monster trudging around on the A roads. But he does say that you can't see its legs.
所以怪物当时正在路上溜达。对。对。没错。一个从未被重复过的描述。所以怪物当时正在路上溜达。对。对。没错。一个从未被重复过的描述。所以从没有其他人见过怪物在A级公路上蹒跚而行。但他确实说过你看不见它的腿。
So the opportunity for it actually to have flippers and perhaps it's hauling itself out of the ground, out of the water, is still there. So this description gets taken to a naturalist who says that that it was almost certainly an otter which must have been an enormous otter 25 feet long right so this is this is what this is what uh mr spice's reply that um the creature he had seen was far too big to be an otter and spice goes on to say it should definitely be killed yeah that's that's the british spirit the English spirit, isn't it? Shoot it. So this kickstarts a huge amount of interest, doesn't it, in the press? Well, of course.
因此，它实际上长着鳍肢、并且也许正把自己从地面上、从水里拖出来的可能性依然存在。所以这个描述被拿给了一位自然学家，他说这几乎可以肯定是一只水獭，那必定是一只足足有25英尺长的巨大水獭，对吧？所以，这就是斯派塞先生的回复，他所看到的生物远太大，不可能是水獭，斯派塞接着说，它绝对应该被杀死。是的，这就是英国精神，英国精神，对吧？开枪打死它。所以这在媒体中引发了极大的关注，对吧？嗯，当然。
Because people presumably believe Mr Spicer is telling the truth. Yes. Well, you've got this reputable gentleman's tailor from London, and you've got this water bailiff who is you know the ghillie that kind of sort of the earth figure from a john buckham novel all that kind of thing again absolutely trustworthy and the pair of them their evidence combines to imply that there is this creature with a very long curvy neck and it's campbell who says this is a plesiosaur and that's what then really kick-starts it because it's not just a monster but it's a scientific monster yeah so it could
因为人们大概相信斯派塞先生说的是实话。是的。你看，你有这位来自伦敦的声誉良好的绅士裁缝，还有这位水警长，你知道，他就是《约克郡人》或约翰·巴坎（John Buchan）小说里那种具有大地气息的人物，诸如此类，同样绝对值得信赖，他们两人的证据结合起来暗示，确实存在这样一种有着长长弯曲脖子的生物，而且正是坎贝尔说这是一只蛇颈龙，这才是真正让它火起来的原因，因为它不仅仅是一个怪物，而是一个科学的怪物。是的，所以它可能
be a kind of prehistoric hangover and that's really I think what what gets people excited and so from then on you start to get this cascade effect so you in november 19 1933 you get the first photograph or at least alleged photograph um a photograph that by a man called hugh gray and i see from your notes it says um a photograph that's actually believed to be of his own dog getting a stick from the lock so i mean i hope if there are a lot Ness Monster enthusiasts into this who are dismayed by my skepticism, I have to warn you there is more skepticism to come. Yes. But yeah, so that photograph is not definitive evidence. I think it's fair to say, Tom.
是一种史前遗留物，我认为这正是让人兴奋的原因，所以从那时起，你开始看到这种瀑布效应。所以在1933年11月19日，你得到了第一张照片，或者至少是所谓的照片，一张由一个叫休·格雷（Hugh Gray）的人拍摄的照片。我从你的笔记中看到，上面写着……一张据信实际上是拍他自己的狗从湖里叼树枝的照片。所以，如果有许多尼斯湖水怪爱好者看到这里并对我的怀疑态度感到沮丧，我不得不警告你们，还有更多的怀疑要登场。是的。但是，是的，所以那张照片并不是决定性的证据，我觉得这样说很公道，汤姆。
And then what hots up is that you start to get eccentric figures coming up. The kind of the image of the big game hunter or the uh kind of professor challenger figure from the the conan doyle stories so um the first monster hunter is a man called commander rupert gould who as his title implies had been in the navy um he was very kind of eccentric uh man who loved going down rabbit holes to some effect because he is the man who um discovered uh john harrison's chronometers which are you know the the latitude guy okay uh and he'd found these chronometers uh kind of buried away in the um uh the national maritime museum in greenwich and he got them finding some chronometers in the museum it's not the same as finding a monster in a lock it's not but you know
然后，事情升温的地方在于，你开始看到一些古怪的人物出现。那种大猎游戏猎人（big game hunter）的形象，或者柯南·道尔小说里查林杰教授（Professor Challenger）那种人物。所以，第一个怪物猎人是一个名叫鲁珀特·古尔德（Rupert Gould）中校的人，正如他的头衔所暗示的那样，他曾在海军服役。他是一个非常古怪的人，喜欢钻研牛角尖并取得了一定成果，因为他就是那个……发现了约翰·哈里森（John Harrison）精密计时器的人，你知道的，就是那个搞纬度的家伙，好吧。他发现了这些计时器，它们被埋在格林尼治的国家海事博物馆里，他把它们找了出来。在博物馆里找到几个计时器，跟在湖里找到一个怪物是不一样的。确实不一样，但是，你知道的，
these chronometers are a big deal and they've been ignored and he's dusted them down and he's produced them so he has this i'll tell you now we're not doing a podcast about the chronometer i know we're not i know we're not but he is also when he's not mending chronometers he's obsessed by the idea of sea monsters the idea that there are long neck creatures out in the out in the the ocean but he's the obvious person to turn to with the idea of sea monsters the idea that there are long neck creatures out in the out in the the ocean but he's the obvious person to turn to with the idea that maybe it's you know it's actually in this this lock um and he gets funding from a guy who is um he's the heir to i think it's dundee marmalade which is the most popular very big marmalade big big marmalade in uh in 1930s britain um a guy called alexander keeler who is uh has the nymphomaniac qualities um he's a sex addict
这些计时器是一件大事，它们曾被忽视，而他把上面的灰尘拂去，将它们展示出来。所以他有这个……我现在就告诉你，我们不是在做一个关于计时器的播客。我知道我们不是。我知道我们不是。但他同时——当他不修理计时器的时候——他痴迷于海怪的想法，痴迷于海洋中存在长脖子生物的想法。但他显然是向其征询海怪想法的最佳人选，认为海洋中存在长脖子生物的想法，但他显然是向其征询这种想法的最佳人选——也许它，你知道的，实际上就在这个湖里。他从一个人那里得到了资金，这个人是……我想他是邓迪橘子酱（Dundee marmalade）的继承人，这是20世纪30年代英国最受欢迎、规模非常大的橘子酱品牌，一个叫亚历克斯·基勒（Alexander Keeler）的人，他有一种性瘾倾向。
so when he's when he's not being a sex addict he's he's funding uh commander rupert gould to go after the loch ness monster however howeverupert Gould is not the only hunter, and this, Dominic, is where Britain's best-loved newspaper comes in. Well, just before we come to Britain's best-loved newspaper, I just want to put forward a theory, which is, of course, we're in the 1930s, so the world has been mapped, and the days of Victorian explorers are kind of over, aren't they? I mean, even the poles have been conquered.
所以，当他不是在发性瘾的时候，他就在资助鲁珀特·古尔德中校去追捕尼斯湖水怪。然而，鲁珀特·古尔德并不是唯一的猎人，多米尼克，这就是英国最受欢迎的报纸登场的地方。嗯，在我们讲到英国最受欢迎的报纸之前，我只是想提出一个理论，那就是，当然，我们正处于20世纪30年代，所以世界已经被测绘过了，维多利亚时代探险家的时代已经基本结束了，对吧？我的意思是，连两极都被征服了。
So the obsession with creatures of the deep, I mean, this is a generation that has... Actually, you mentioned Professor Challenger. These are now people who have grown up reading Conan Dore's The Lost World, I suppose, aren't they? And there are no more worlds to conquer other than the deeps. And so if you if you if you fantasize about lost kingdoms or or you know surviving dinosaurs the oceans are really the only
所以对深海生物的迷恋——我的意思是，这是一代人……事实上，你提到了查林杰教授。这些人现在都是读着柯南·道尔的《失落的世界》长大的一代，我猜，对吧？除了深海之外，已经没有其他世界可供征服了。所以，如果你幻想失落的王国，或者你知道的，幸存的恐龙，海洋真的是唯一的
place to look i suppose do you think tom i think that's absolutely true well let's let's look at this further when we've described the next character who turns okay so you mentioned um the newspapers uh and the newspaper in question is the daily mail so for people i know we have a lot of overseas listeners so that's basically the british equivalent of le monde or um newspaper record i think people call it uh that's not that's not entirely true um is there an equivalent of the daily mail in other countries i'm not sure it's i think i think these days it's actually the daily mail i mean it's um it's it's much detested by people on the left um much written for by people like dominic well would be fair to say
可以寻找的地方，我猜。你觉得呢，汤姆？我认为这绝对是真的。好吧，当我们介绍完下一个出场的人物后，我们再进一步探讨这个问题。好吧，你提到了……报纸，有关的报纸就是《每日邮报》。所以对于大家——我知道我们有很多海外听众——这基本上就是英国版的《世界报》（Le Monde）或者……《纪事报》（Chronicle），我想人们会这么叫它。那并非……那并非完全正确。其他国家有没有类似于《每日邮报》的报纸？我不确定。我觉得现在它其实就是《每日邮报》本身。我的意思是，左翼人士非常讨厌它……多米尼克这样的人经常为它写稿。这么说公允吗？
uh well the daily mail is enormous in the popular culture of the early 20th century so it's founded in the 1890s by alfred harmsworth and um it is sort of attention-grabbing journalism uh and what the daily mail does a lot in the 1920s and 30s is stunts and wheezes so they're always sending people to discover things or they're investigating mysteries or they're always sending people to discover things or they're investigating mysteries or they're inventing hats or they're sponsoring you know the first um british radio broadcast nelly melba on the top of a department store so they're always doing these kind of they've constantly got gimmicks i guess yeah and this maintains their audience i mean their core audience which is a sort of populist audience, sort of lower middle class,
嗯，《每日邮报》在20世纪初的流行文化中规模巨大。它是由阿尔弗雷德·哈姆斯沃思（Alfred Harmsworth）在1890年代创立的，是一种吸引眼球的新闻业。20世纪20和30年代，《每日邮报》经常搞一些噱头和花招，所以他们总是派人去发现一些东西，或者调查神秘事件；或者他们总是派人去发现一些东西，或者调查神秘事件；或者他们发明帽子；或者他们赞助（你知道的）第一次英国广播，内莉·梅尔巴（Nellie Melba）在百货公司屋顶上的演出。所以他们总是在做这些事情，他们不断有各种花招，我猜，是的，这维持了他们的受众。我的意思是，他们的核心受众是某种平民主义受众，有点像中产阶级下层，
ordinary people who can't be bothered to read The Times, which is also owned by the same newspaper baron at one point. They don't want to wade through sort of turgid prose, sort of column after column of it. They want fun and they want sensation. And this is before television so it's yeah it's a kind of it's the closest you get to uh you know i guess kind of documentary about aliens on the history channel or something like that right that's basically what's going on here because they see the editorial
普通人懒得去读《泰晤士报》（该报一度也由同一位报业大亨拥有）。他们不想去读那些沉闷的散文，一栏又一栏的那种。他们想要乐趣，想要轰动效应。在电视出现之前，这就是……是的，这最接近于你在历史频道上看到的关于外星人的纪录片之类的内容，对吧？这基本上就是这里正在发生的事情，因为他们看到编辑
team see the photograph that may be of this dog but it's being marketed as the photograph of a monster and so they decide that they want proof and they want to blazon it over the front page of the newspaper. And so this is the first intrusion of the London press into the story. So up to now, it's all been local newspapers, particularly based in Inverness. And so suddenly the London press turning its attention to Loch Ness and they employ, even as Commander Gould is out on his boat
团队看到了那张可能是这只狗的照片，但它被作为怪物的照片进行营销，所以他们决定他们想要证据，并想把它大肆宣传在报纸的头版。因此，这是伦敦媒体对这个故事的首次介入。在此之前，全都是地方报纸，特别是总部设在因弗内斯的报纸。因此，伦敦媒体突然将注意力转向尼斯湖，他们雇用了——就在古尔德中校在船上搜寻怪物的时候——他们雇用了名字叫马马杜克·韦瑟罗尔（Marmaduke Wetherall）的非凡人物。你简直编不出这样的人，因为他太棒了。不，不。所以他是个演员，但也是个大猎游戏猎人。你知道他演过什么吗？他演过……他曾在自己导演和编剧的电影中扮演过大卫·利文斯廷（David Livingstone）和鲁滨逊·克鲁索（Robinson Crusoe），是的，这就是我们要打交道的那种人，绝对是。而且那种感觉——他既是……他是一个演员，曾扮演过深入非洲进行伟大探索的人，比如大卫·利文斯廷，但他同时也是
hunting for the monster, they employ an extraordinary figure called Marmaduke Wetherall. You couldn't make him up because he's great. No, no. So he's an actor, but he's also a big game hunter. Do you know what he'd performed in? he'd performed in he'd he'd played both david livingston and robinson crusoe in films he directed and written himself yeah that's the kind of man we're dealing with absolutely and that sense that he's both he's he's an actor who's kind
一个去过非洲探险的大猎游戏猎人——这绝对带有30年代早期那种氛围的印记，我认为，对吧？维多利亚时代孤注一掷的勇气和帝国冒险传统的那些方式开始互相吞噬，因为实际上，正如你所说，世界上没有多少地方未被探索了。所以，如果你想要惊险刺激和探险家，你需要开始转移到电影中去，比如亚马逊的失落山谷之类的地方。显然有一个非常明显的电影例子，等我们盘点完所有的目击事件后会谈到。但当然，韦瑟罗尔不能承受回来后说这全是骗局的代价，对吧？我的意思是，
of played people who've been into africa on great quests like david livingstone but he's also um a big game hunter who's been to Africa on quests is absolutely kind of redolent of that mood in the early 30s I think isn't it of the way in which the kind of the traditions of Victorian daring do and imperial adventuring are starting to cannibalize themselves because actually you know there's as you say there's not much of the world left unexplored and so if you're going to have thrills and spills and explorers you need to start migrating to to film you know lost valleys of the amazons or whatever and and there's obviously a very obvious cinematic example of this that we'll come to when we've finished our roundup of uh of all the sightings but of course wetherill cannot afford to come back and say it's all hokum can he i mean
这既符合《每日邮报》的利益，但最重要的是符合他自己的利益，即他这个蓄着胡子的……你知道的，这个……正如你所说的那种查林杰教授似的人物，那个阿瑟·柯南·道尔笔下的角色，他绝对需要带回点什么。头两天，他什么也没找到。然后到了第三天，汤姆，发生了什么？所以在第三天，他来到了那种真正荒凉的东部边境，即韦德将军路（General Wade's Road）路边，那里主要是岩石，所以泥土非常少。但他偶然发现了一小片泥地，在那里非同寻常地有一些令人惊叹的脚印，它们有八英寸
it's but it's both in the daily mail's interests but crucially in his interests that he this sort of bearded you know this this sort of professor challenger figure as you say the arthur cody character he absolutely needs to come back with something. And for two days, he finds nothing. And then on the third day, Tom, what happens? So on the third day, he's on the kind of the really wild eastern side, the General Wade's Roadside, which is mainly rock. So very little mud but he comes across a very short patch of mud and there remarkably are some stunning prints and they're eight inches
宽，有四个短短的有爪脚趾，它们看起来有点像河马，但显然不可能是河马，因为你在尼斯湖怪物里找不到河马……在附近还有另一组脚印……这显然是一次巨大的运气，因为看来怪物——如果它是怪物的话——走过了极少数能留下它足迹印记的地段之一。多么棒的回答。真是个笑话。难以置信。因此，韦瑟罗尔拍电报给《每日邮报》，说已经找到了怪物，《报纸》撤下了头条。《尼斯湖怪物不是传说而是事实》。嗯，这就是那种轻描淡写的头条新闻，
across they've got four short clawed toes and they look a little bit like a hippopotamus but obviously it can't be a hippopotamus because you don't know hippopotamuses in uh in Loch Ness monsters um and nearby another set of of uh of prints uh and this is obviously a massive stroke of luck because it seems that the monster if it is the monster has walked across one of the very few stretches where the imprint of its footprints would be left. What a great answer. What a joke. Incredible. And so, whether or not it wires back to the Daily Mail, have found the monster, and the Mail clears its headlines. Monster of Loch Ness is not a legend but a fact. Well, that's the kind of understated headline
你绝对会期待的。所以，极度兴奋。只有在他们发表了头条新闻之后，他们才把脚印送到伦敦自然历史博物馆，看他们能否……识别它。自然历史博物馆说，是的，嗯，他们说这不可能是英伦三岛任何已知水生哺乳动物的脚印，但他们继续进行研究，在新年，也就是1934年初，他们透露这实际上是河马的脚印。而且这是一个单脚印。换句话说，这是一个河马的单一脚印，被一遍又一遍地按压进泥土里，以使其看起来像是有多个脚印。自然历史博物馆暗示，这是一件狩猎战利品，一个河马的脚，
you would absolutely expect. So, huge excitement. And only once they've run the headline do they then send the prints to the natural history museum in london to see if they can um identify it and they say the natural history is in say yeah well they say that it is not the impression of any known aquatic mammal in the british isles um but they continue to do the research uh And in the new year, so early 1934, they reveal that it is in fact a hippopotamus footprints. And it's a single footprint. So in other words, it's a single footprint of a hippopotamus that has been pressed down into the mud over and over again to make it look like there are multiple footprints. And the Natural History Museum suggests that it's a hunting trophy, a hippopotamus foot,
被改造成了一个伞架，这非常符合那种……这真是一个极具1930年代风格的故事。你杀死了一只河马，然后把它的一条腿做成了一个伞架。所以我认为这个故事对马马杜克·韦瑟罗尔的评价很好，事实上，因为他是一个显然有先见之明的人，在行李里带了一个河马脚伞架去苏格兰，以防万一。以防万一。
that's been converted into an umbrella stand, which is very much the kind of thing that... That's such a 1930s story. You kill a hippopotamus and you turn one of its legs into an umbrella stand. So I think this is a story that speaks very well of Marmaduke Wetherill, actually, because he is a man who clearly had the foresight to travel to Scotland with a hippopotamus foot umbrella stand in his luggage just in case. Just in case.
继续。嗯，我觉得更有可能不是他，而是别人做的，是在取笑他，我想是的，因为正如我们将发现的那样，韦瑟罗尔对此感到难以置信的心烦意乱，他特别沮丧的是，《邮报》在他在危急关头时没有支持他们的男人，反而反咬一口，叫他笨蛋，并因他的无能而狠狠地嘲笑他。这登上了头版，我简直不敢相信他们会做出这样的事，汤姆。令人震惊的行为，这和你在现在能得到的任何东西都非常不一样。所以……所以韦瑟罗尔感到非常非常的痛苦，
Go on. Well, I think more probably it wasn't him it was someone else who did it who was making fun of him i think so yeah because as we will find out whether or is unbelievably upset by this and he's particularly upset by the fact that the male rather than standing by their man in his his hour of need turn on him and call him an idiot and mock him roundly for his incompetence mcgain goes all over the front page i can't believe they would have done something like that tom shocking behavior and very unlike anything you get from it now so uh so wetherill is left very very embittered and
对《邮报》以及参与搜寻尼斯湖水怪的所有人都怀恨在心。所以他退缩了，舔舐着他的伤口。但在1934年的进程中，更多非凡的发展发生了。所以，同样地，你找到了那些能够切中要害的目击者，他们是每个人都能认出的、声誉良好且可靠的目击者。所以在1月上旬，你有一个骑摩托车的兽医
with a big grudge against the mail and against um everybody involved in the search for Nessie. So he withdraws, licking his wounds. But over the course of 1934, more and more extraordinary developments happen. So, and again, you get people, the witnesses who cut through are witnesses who everyone can recognize as being reputable and reliable. So early in January, you have a veterinary
学生差点撞上怪物。所以，多米尼克，这是另一个怪物在外面溜达、四处滚动的例子，对吧？奇怪的是，现在这种事不怎么发生了，但……而且那个兽医学生再次说，它看起来完全像一只蛇颈龙。然后在4月份，堆积起来的4月份，你得到了可能是最核心的证据，它的形式是一张照片，而且是一张比那个看起来像狗头的照片好得多的照片。事实上，我甚至可以说它是20世纪最著名的照片之一。它是，你知道的，那是每个人都见过的照片。是的，是的，这就是著名的、为这个播客做宣传的照片。
student on a motorbike who almost runs into the monster so dominic that's another one where the monster is out of the out and about rolling around doesn't i mean odd that it doesn't happen so much these days but uh and and and the the veterinary student again says that it looks exactly like a plesiosaur so and then in april stacking up in april you get probably the the key piece of evidence and it's in the form of a photograph and it's much a much better photograph than the photograph that looks like a dog's head and in fact i would go so far as to say it's one of the most famous photographs of the 20th century it is you know it's the photograph that everybody's seen yeah yeah it's the famous publicized this podcast with.
是的。所以它看起来像一只蛇颈龙。你就是这么形容它的。它是一个长脖子生物，隐约露出背部。周围有一些涟漪，黑白的。如果你见过，你就会认出来。这就是所谓的“外科医生照片”。它拍摄于1934年4月。
Yeah. So it looks like a plesiosaur. That's how you would describe it. It's a long neck creature with a hint of back. And there are kind of ripples around it, black and white. And you would know it if you've seen it. And this is known as the surgeon's photo. And it was taken in April 1934.
之所以被称为“外科医生照片”，是因为拍摄它的人既是一位外科医生，又不想透露姓名，而这种沉默寡言再次被视为暗示照片准确性的因素，因为他显然不是为了出名，他不是为了出名。结果证明，这个外科医生是一个名叫罗伯特·威尔逊（Robert Wilson）的人，他是一位妇科医生，在哈雷街（Harley Street）有诊所。这个整体——我的另一个感觉是，这又是另一个似乎从巴坎小说中跃然纸上的角色，带有帝国孤注一掷冒险故事的暗示。他出生在马达加斯加，是传教士的儿子。他在英格兰上寄宿学校。他在第一次世界大战期间
And it's called the surgeon's photo because the person who took it was both a surgeon but didn't want to to be named and again this reticence was seen as something that suggested that you know the accuracy of it because he clearly wasn't after publicity he's not after publicity um and it it turns out so that the surgeon is a man called robert wilson um who's a gynecologist has rooms off harley street and the whole i mean again this is another character who seems sprung from a bucking novel um the the kind of the hint of tales of imperial daring do so he is born in madagascar he's the son of missionaries um he goes to boarding school in England uh the he he comes
成年。在他成年那天，他冲去参军，在第一次世界大战中英勇服役表现出色，受到嘉奖，回来后建立了自己的医疗诊所。他就是提供这张照片的人。《每日邮报》拿到了它，对其进行了裁剪，使其看起来尽可能具有震撼力，并把它放在头版。真的，正是这张照片让它不仅成为全国热议的话题，而且成为全球热议的话题。基本上每个人都对此着迷，以至于连尼斯湖水怪选区的国会议员都卷入了其中。因此，默多克·麦克唐纳（Sir Murdoch MacDonald）爵士，因弗内斯郡的国会议员，在8月8日清晨开车和他的儿子一起出行时，
of age during the first world war the day that he becomes of age he rushes off enlists serves very valiantly and well in the in the first world war gets mentioned in dispatches uh comes back sets up his medical practice um and he is the person who produces this photo and the the daily mail get hold of it they cop it to make it look as impressive as possible they put it on the front page and really that is the photograph that makes it not just a global a national talking point, but a global talking point. And basically everyone is obsessed by it to the degree that even Nessie's MP runs into it. So Sir Murdoch MacDonald, who's the MP for Invernessshire, and he's driving with his son early on the morning
他看到了尼斯湖水怪，他最著名的选民。那是两块缓慢向南移动的黑灰色驼峰。不仅国会议员看到了它。它还被看到——我这里引用加雷斯·威廉姆斯（Gareth Williams）的《一场可怕的骚动》（A Monstrous Commotion）这本好书中的话——“据目击，现场有一名半裸的约克郡人，他带着望远镜从大篷车里跳出来，确认它既不是树干也不是船。”这位国会议员当时正要去见苏格兰事务大臣，后者欣然接受怪物作为他们会议迟到的合理借口。
of the 8th of August, and he sees Nessie, his most famous constituent. And it's two blackish grey humps moving slowly south. And it's not just the MP who sees it. It's also seen, and I'm quoting here, Gareth Williams, A Monstrous Commotion, his great book, says the site was witnessed by a semi-naked Yorkshireman who sprang out of his caravan with binoculars and confirmed that it was neither a tree trunk nor a boat. The MP was on his way to see the Secretary of State for Scotland, who was happy to accept the monster as a reasonable excuse
所以你有一位国会议员，你有一位半裸的约克郡人，你有一位兽医学生，你有一位外科医生，你有一位水警长，你有一位绅士裁缝。这是一组非常非常受人尊敬的人物。尽管，有一位绅士裁缝。好吧。我的怀疑被彻底粉碎了。这些是一组非常非常受人尊敬的人物。尽管，外科医生的照片——我们都非常熟悉的那张照片——人们在生活时对它进行了非常仔细的分析，讨论了水波纹。他们确实分析过。
for starting their meeting late. So you've had an MP, you've had a semi-naked Yorkshireman, you've had a veterinary student, you've had a surgeon, you've had a water bailiff, you've had a gentleman's tailor. A broad array of very, very respectable figures. Although, had a gentleman's tailor. Okay. My skepticism is routed. These are a broad array of very, very respectable figures. Although, so the surgeon's photograph, the photograph that we're all very familiar with, people have analysed it very closely when they live, discussed the ripples. They have.
他们确实分析过。我的理解没错的话，外科医生的照片有个转折？有一个转折。我们现在应该揭晓这个转折还是说出来？嗯，由你选择。你玩得很开心。你玩得太开心了，我让你来决定。好吧，这个转折是，这个搜寻——我想这在90年代被发现，令所有人大失所望——它是一个赝品，是由我们的老朋友马马杜克·韦瑟罗尔与罗伯特·威尔逊的一个同伙伪造的。
They have. And am I right in thinking there is a twist with the surgeon's photograph? There is a twist. Should we reveal the twist now or should we say it? Well, it's your choice. You're enjoying yourself're enjoying yourself far too much i'm gonna let you decide okay so the the twist is that the search and this was discovered i think in the 90s to everyone's huge disappointment that it was a fake and it was faked by our old friend marmaduke wetherall who did it with an associate of robert wilson
他们去了一个……你知道的，湖泊的浅水区，做了一个模型并拍了照片。基本上，如果你看《邮报》头版裁剪之前的原始照片，它看起来比著名版本更像个假货。他们买了一个玩具潜水艇，对吧？他们做了一个木制的东西放在顶部，是的，嗯……基本上，韦瑟罗尔这样做是为了报复。但某种程度上，笑话落在了他自己头上，因为你说得对，每个人都把这当真。他本想通过让《邮报》在头版刊登这个故事来把《邮报》当傻子耍，但他们真的登了，而且获得了巨大的成功，极大地推动了发行量。万岁！是的，是的。所以，正如……作为报复，它并不是很成功。
and they went to a kind of you know a a shallow part of the lock and they made a model of it and they photographed it and basically if you look at the original photo before it got cropped by the to go on the front page of the mail um it it looks much more like a fake than it does in the the famous version of it um and they bought a toy submarine hadn't they and they made a sort of wooden a wooden thing to go on the top yeah um and um basically wetherill did it to get his own back uh but in a way the laugh was on him because you're right everyone i read this so seriously he he thought this he would make fools of the mail by getting them to print this story on the front page um but they did and it was tremendously
那不是蝾螈。那不是蝾螈。但当然，那就是我们现在看到的形象。所以它是恐龙的形象，对吧？我想在20世纪30年代，你知道这是一个对恐龙有巨大科学兴趣、大众兴趣的时代，所以你能看出为什么它能吸引公众的想象力。但我认为……我的意思是，我们讨论了电影，我们讨论了人们前往世界偏远地区的冒险故事，因为基本上世界上已经没有什么偏远地区了。而其中最著名的电影例子就是《金刚》。
successful massively boosted the circulation hurrah yes yeah so um as as sort of yeah as revenge goes it wasn't very successful now that that's not a salamander it's not a salamander but that of course is the image that we now so it's the a salamander it's not a sound but that of course is the image that we now so it's the dinosaur image isn't it and i suppose the 1930s you know it's an age of tremendous scientific interest in dinosaurs of popular interest so you can see white courts the public imagination but i think i think that i i mean we talked about um film and we talked about adventure stories where people go to remote areas of the world because basically there aren't any remote areas of the world anymore. And the most famous cinematic example of that is King Kong.
是的。《金刚》于1933年春天在伦敦上映。我认为它在夏天就传到了因弗内斯。哦，太棒了！在《金刚》中——我不知道你是否还记得——有一个情节是这样的：金刚被带回纽约，爬上了帝国大厦，每个人都知道这个故事。但在岛上，金刚生活在那里，周围都是恐龙。那些前去捕捉金刚并把菲伊·雷（Fay Wray）从它手里救回的大猎游戏猎人，作为探险的一部分，
Yeah. And King Kong comes out in London in spring 1933. And it comes out in, I think think it reaches inferness by the summer oh very good and in king kong um i don't know if you remember it there's a sequence where so king kong is uh it's you know king kong is the giant gorilla gets brought back to new york and climbs the empire state building everyone knows that story. But on the island, King Kong lives there surrounded by dinosaurs. And the big game hunters who are going off
被看到穿过一片沼泽，一只长脖子恐龙（也就是蜥脚类恐龙）从里面浮现出来。蜥脚类恐龙是素食的、食草的，但在电影里它们非常肉食且凶猛。它们发起攻击，把船弄翻，然后怪物在丛林中追逐逃跑的探险家。而《金刚》中那个怪物的侧影，
to capture King Kong and get Fay Wray back from him, as part of this expedition, are shown crossing a swamp in which a long-necked dinosaur, so a sauropod, emerges. Sauropods were vegetarian, herbivorous, but in this they're very carnivorous and ferocious. And they attack, they upend the boat, and then the monster chases the fleeing explorers through the jungle. And the profile of that monster in King Kong
非常非常像许多画作，以及随后的照片——你得到的那个外科医生的照片。我认为很难不认为它受到了《金刚》的影响，因为怪物被描述为蛇颈龙的程度，几乎与《金刚》的上映时间完全吻合。是的，我的意思是——我确信不是刻意的，但它就是这样一个戏剧性的形象。正如你所说，我认为这是一种表达，表达了人们在万物都在缩小的世界里，对那些遥远国度里的冒险故事的渴望。嗯，你刚才谈到了汽车驾驶，对吧？所以……
is very, very like a lot of the drawings. And then in due course, the photograph, the surgeon's photograph that you get. And it's hard, I think, hard to think that it's not influencing it. Because the degree to which the monster comes to be described as a plesiosaur almost exactly maps onto the the the screening of of king kong yeah i mean i'm i'm sure not deliberately but it's just such a kind of dramatic um such a dramatic image and you know as you say i think i think that it is a kind of an expression of you know a yearning for those tales of of daring doing distant climbs in a world where everything is closing in well you were talking about motoring weren't you so i mean
30年代是汽车驾驶的黄金时代，人们第一次买得起汽车、有了新公路等等。是的，所以公路也得到了升级。所以高地在某种程度上向许多游客开放了。因此，旅游业正在腾飞。但与此同时，我猜人们也有一种焦虑，即世界正在变得……你知道的，这种我们今天非常熟悉的焦虑：世界正在变得全球化和同质化，因此人们渴望让某些地方保持这种浪漫的、史诗般的宏大感、神秘感以及某种原始主义，我想。我的意思是，这就是苏格兰政府最近在英国引发关于尼斯湖头条新闻的教育材料所指出的，对吧？
the 30s is a hate is a golden age of motoring people getting cars for the first time new roads and so on yeah so the road has been given an upgrade yeah as well that's so the highlands have kind of been opened up to an extent to lots of visitors. So you've got a tourist industry that is taking off. But at the same time, I suppose there's also an anxiety that the world is becoming, you know, the anxiety that we're so familiar with today, that the world is becoming globalized and homogenized and a yearning, therefore, for places to have this kind of romantic, epic grandeur and mystery and this sort of primitivism, I suppose. I mean, this is what the Scottish government's education materials that recently caused headlines in Britain about Loch Ness. This is what they point out, isn't it?
这就是他们所指出的，对吧？这就是他们所说的，尼斯湖水怪在某种程度上是苏格兰浪漫化的一部分，正如你用苏格兰短裙、格子呢、罗布·罗伊（Rob Roy）、《勇敢的心》所得到的那样。难道你不认为，汤姆，其中有一点这种成分吗？它将苏格兰定位为一个有恐龙的地方，这与国际大都会、都市化的英格兰或更鲜明地说是苏格兰低地形成了对比，因为这绝对是一个苏格兰的故事。我的意思是，你知道的，《每日邮报》作为一个局外人从伦敦轰轰烈烈地闯进来，但它绝对不是
This is what they say, that the Loch Ness. This is what they point out, isn't it? This is what they say, that the Loch Ness Monster is, in a way, it's part of the same kind of romanticisation of Scotland as you get with Kilt, Tartan, Rob Roy, Braveheart. Do you not think, Tom, there's a bit of that about it? It sort of locates Scotland as a place where there are dinosaurs in contrast to cosmopolitan metropolitan urban england or the lowlands of scotland more pointedly because it's absolutely a scottish story i mean that you know the the daily mail comes crashing in from london as an outsider but it's absolutely not
一个英国的发明，它不是一个英国的投影。我看到亚历克斯·马西（Alex Massey）——一位非常杰出的记者和专栏作家——带着调侃的语气在打听这件事。尼斯湖水怪源自苏格兰传统，最初是苏格兰人看到了它。当然，尼斯湖水怪一直是苏格兰向世界展示自己的一个根本部分。它是旅游基础设施的关键部分。它将人们带到高地。而这是从一开始就开始的事情，你正在让……所以人们是……
um an english invention it's not a an english projection um i saw Alex Massey, a very distinguished journalist and columnist, rather, I mean, his kind of tongue firmly in his cheek was asking about this. It's Loch Ness Monster comes from Scottish traditions and it's Scots who initially see it. And of course, Loch Ness Monster has been a fundamental part of how Scotland marks itself to the world. It's a crucial part of the tourist infrastructure. It brings people to the highlands. And that is something that starts right from the beginning, that you are having... So people are...
巨量的人在1933年和1934年涌向尼斯湖。有一个非凡的故事。尼尔·K（Neil K）在Discord上向我透露了这一点：苏格兰的第一批足球场泛光灯被拆下来用来照亮湖泊。这是由因弗内斯的卡利多尼安足球俱乐部（Caledonian FC）架设的。这非常具有创新性。他们是全国第一家以这种方式使用泛光灯的足球俱乐部。
Huge, huge numbers descend on Loch Ness over 1933 and 34. There's this extraordinary story. I was tipped off about this by Neil K on the Discord, that Scotland's first football floodlights were taken away to be used to highlight the lock. So this has been put up by Caledonian FC and Inverness. And this was kind of very innovative. They were the first football club in the country to use floodlights in this
我想他们大概只用了三四场比赛。然后有人买下它们，把它们架设在尼斯湖岸边，试图以此来照亮怪物的存在。这个可怜的俱乐部直到1959年才拿回他们的泛光灯，这非常令人难过。但是在战后的岁月中——到这个时候，怪物大概已经融入了国家想象力、世界的想象力，成为旅游业的一部分——但你确实得到了相当杰出的人物，对吧？你确实得到了一个曾担任鱼类学馆长的人……
way. And I think they've used them for about three or four games. And um somebody bought them to put up on the shores of loch ness to to kind of try and highlight um the presence of the monster and the poor club only got their floodlights back again in 1959 which is very sad um but people throughout the post-war years so by this point the monster had i guess become embedded in the national imagination in the world's imagination become part of the the tourist industry but you do get quite distinguished people don't you you do a man who was the curator of fishes at the map well so one of the things one of the things that happens just before the world goes into war and i think also one of the one of
好吧，所以在世界陷入战争之前发生的事情之一——我认为这也是1933年和1934年它爆发的其他原因之一——是大萧条、希特勒在德国掌权。这是一个非常黑暗的时期，人们想要振作起来，这是一个完美的故事。我认为这实际上有点像图坦卡蒙的发现，它是一个好的新闻故事，是一场探险。我确信图坦卡蒙的阴影——它同样与媒体、探险、戏剧性人物、大猎游戏人物有这种交集，所有这些你可能会从电影中认出的角色阵容——与尼斯湖水怪非常相似，只是省去了你不用一直远赴埃及的麻烦，你知道的，它就在英国，它就在你的家门口等待着。
the other reasons why it kicks off in 1933 and 34 is this the depression it's coming to power of hitler in germany it's a really dark time and people want cheering up and it's a kind of perfect story and i think that that that it's a bit actually a bit like the discovery of tutankhamen it's a good new story and it's a quest and i'm sure that the shadow of tutankhamen which again has this kind of interface with the press quests dramatic characters kind of big game figures all these kind of you know panoply of characters who you might recognize from a film very similar with loch ness except with the convenience you don't have to go all the way to egypt you know yeah it's
但我认为，确实有一件事提升了整个叙事，使其超越了《金刚》的水平：1938年，在南非附近水域发现了一种名为腔棘鱼（coelacanth）的鱼。人们原本认为腔棘鱼是一种非常非常古老的鱼。它基本上自——我想是3.5亿年前——就存在了，而且由于在那之后没有化石痕迹，人们认为它已经与恐龙一起灭绝了。
there in britain it's kind of waiting on your doorstep. But one of the things I think that does serve to elevate the whole narrative above a kind of King Kong level is in 1938, a fish called the coelacanth is discovered in waters off South Africa. And the coelacanth had been thought, you know, it's a very, very ancient fish. It had basically been around since, I think, 350 million years old, something like that, and was thought to have gone extinct with the dinosaurs because there was no fossil trace of it after that.
然后它在1938年被发现了。所以突然之间，人们认为已经灭绝的生物可能并没有灭绝的观点在科学上是站得住脚的。这是一种贯穿战争年代、40年代进入50年代的信念。是的，正如你所说，所以在50年代，自然历史博物馆的鱼类馆长——所以他是一个对腔棘鱼及其含义了如指掌的人——他在尼斯湖。他看到一个巨大的驼峰状物体穿过水面，他确信那是蛇颈龙，他赶忙回去告诉了每个人。
And then it got discovered in 1938. And so suddenly the idea that creatures that had been thought extinct might not have gone extinct is scientifically reputable and that is something that feeds through through the war years through the 40s into the 50s and yes and as you say so so in the 50s um the curator of fishes at the natural history museum so he's a guy who's absolutely on top of cedar camp from the implications of it he's at Loch N. He sees a large humped object going through the water and he's convinced it's a plesiosaur and he rushes back and tells
自然历史博物馆对此并不觉得好笑，他被迫离职。嗯，他大概很想亲眼看看。你觉得呢，汤姆？他想看怪物。是的，很可能。但真正让60年代的整个痴迷状态再次爆发的人是蒂姆·丁斯代尔（Tim Dinsdale），他写了我在这集节目开头提到的那本书。他是一名在希思罗机场工作的航空工程师——我的意思是，最不浪漫的地方莫过于此——他在1960年春天的某个时候在苏格兰高地度假，他看到了尼斯湖水怪，他带着摄像机，他在苏格兰高地度假，在1960年春天的某个时候，他看到了尼斯湖水怪，他带着摄像机，他拍摄了它。正是这段录像，
everyone. And the Natural History Museum are not amused and he gets forced out. Well, he presumably wanted to see it. Do you think, Tom? He wanted to see the monster. Yeah, probably. But the person who really kind of kickstarts the whole obsession again in the 60s is this guy Tim Dinsdale who wrote the book that I mentioned at the start of the of the of this episode who he's a an aeronautical engineer working at Heathrow I mean you know the most unromantic location imaginable and he's on holiday in the highlands in in I think spring 1960 and he sees Nessie and he's got Phil he's got camera and he's on holiday in the highlands in in i think spring 1960 and he sees nessie and he's got phil he's got camera and he films it and it's it's that footage that
人们可以真正地去观看它，这吸引了一个非常非常杰出的人物——彼得·斯科特（Sir Peter Scott）爵士的注意。多米尼克，你曾提到、详细说明了世界是如何缩小的，因为人们已经去过了两极。彼得·斯科特就是南极探险家斯科特的儿子。是的，罗伯特·法尔肯·斯科特（Robert Falcon Scott）。是的，斯科特在南极，我想在他死前不久写给妻子的最后一封信中——
people can actually look at it and this attracts the attention of a very very distinguished figure a man called sir peter scott and domin, you mentioned, you specified how the world is shrinking because people have been to the poles. And Peter Scott is the son of Scott of the Antarctic. Yeah, Robert Falcon Scott. Yeah, and Scott of the Antarctic, in I think his last letter to his wife, just before he dies,
彼得·斯科特当时两岁。他写信给妻子说：“请确保彼得在成长过程中对自然世界充满热爱。”彼得确实在对自然界的热爱中长大了。他变得非常非常杰出。最初他是一名运动员，他打猎——这表现出对大自然极大的热爱——但他后来转变了方向，他成了一名鸟类学家、自然保护主义者，他帮助建立了世界自然基金会。
Peter Scott is two years old at this point. He writes to his wife and says, please make sure that Peter grows up with a love of the natural world. Andeter does grow up with the love of the natural world he becomes very very distinguished initially he's a sportsman he shoots duck that's that shows a great love but but he then kind of turns and he he um he becomes an ornithologist he becomes conservationist he helps to set up the world wildlife fund Fund. I was about to say, as a boy, I went to his wildfowl place at Slimbridge. It was a great place for school outings in the 1970s and 1980s.
我正要说，作为一个男孩，我去过他在斯利姆布里奇（Slimbridge）的野禽保护区。那是20世纪70年代和80年代学校春游的好地方。我猜我们的很多听众也去过那里，并且因为他建立世界自然基金会的角色而知道他。所以他是斯科特的儿子，南极斯科特的儿子，他又是那个帝国冒险时代的遗老。所以他有着非常杰出的战绩，他是一名奥运会运动员——我想他在1936年柏林奥运会的丁字帆船比赛中赢得了铜牌，所以那是希特勒的奥运会——而且丁字帆船比赛是在基尔（Kiel）举行的，他后来回到那里并用皇家空军的飞机轰炸了那里。所以他是一个非常勇敢、潇洒的人。他娶了伊丽莎白·简·霍华德（Elizabeth Jane Howard），后者后来嫁给了……
And I imagine quite a few of our listeners will have been there and will know of him because of his role setting up the World Wildlife Fund. So he's Scott's son,ott the antarctics and he is a a kind of hangover again from that age of imperial daring do so he's very distinguished war record uh he is uh an olympic athlete so he wins bronze i think in the dinghy racing in the the um the berlin olympics of 36 so that's the hitler olympics yeah um and the dinghy racing is held at keel and he then goes back and bombs it with the raf um so he's he's um a very brave kind of dashing man he marries elizabeth jane elizabeth jane howard who then goes on to marry king's
她不是成了马丁·艾米斯（Martin Amis）的继母吗？所以这是一个非常有趣的人。他遇到了丁斯代尔，看了录像，基本上为此着迷，他真的希望尼斯湖水怪是真的。也许其中包含着与他父亲有关的各种情结，我不知道。我的意思是，也许我在过度心理分析它，但也许，你知道的，他想找到某种东西来……是的。
amos doesn't she become martin amos's um stepmother so very interesting man and he he meets up with dinsdale looks at the footage and basically becomes obsessed and becomes he really wants the loch ness monster to be real and perhaps there's all kinds of stuff to do with his father i don't know know. I mean, maybe I'm over psychologizing it there, but perhaps, you know, he wants to find something that would. Yeah.
艾莫斯，她不是成了马丁·艾莫斯的继母吗？所以这是一个非常有趣的人，他与丁斯代尔会面，看了录像，基本上着迷了，并且真的希望尼斯湖水怪是真的，也许这和他的父亲有各种各样的关系，我不知道。我是说，也许我对它进行了过度的心理分析，但也许，你知道，他想找到能证明这一点的东西。是的。
You know, it'd be remarkable and extraordinary, a great quest as his father had gone on. And in the seventies, he, he, he and Dinsdale meet up with an American lawyer from Boston, a man called Robert Rines, who in the early 70s starts using sonar to explore the lock. And in 1972, the sonar picks out a huge shape, plus another photograph of what might, seen from a certain angle, look like a flipper.
你知道，这将是一件非凡而卓越的事情，就像他父亲当年的伟大探索一样。到了70年代，他和邓斯代尔（Dinsdale）遇到了一位来自波士顿的美国律师，名叫罗伯特·莱恩斯（Robert Rines）。他在70年代初开始使用声呐来探索这个湖泊。到了1972年，声呐捕捉到了一个巨大的形状，另外还有一张照片，从某个角度看，可能长得像个鳍。
Yes, I've seen those pictures. Of course, angle, look like a flipper. Yes, I've seen those pictures. Of course, it might not be a flipper. That's the downside of that photo. Well, so these get picked up by a man who anyone interested in royal affairs in Britain will be very, very familiar with, a man called Nicholas Whitchell. This is such a bizarre part of the story. The BBC royal correspondent.
是的，我见过那些照片。当然，从某个角度看，它可能像个鳍。这就是那张照片的局限所在。好吧，这些照片被一个人捕捉到了，任何对英国皇室事务感兴趣的人都会非常非常熟悉他，他叫尼古拉斯·维切尔（Nicholas Witchell）。这是故事中最离奇的部分。他是BBC的皇室事务记者。
Back in the early 70s he was um he was a student uh and he becomes a massive massive kind of nessie twitcher and he writes a book about it um and so scott and uh and dinsdale read nicholas witchell's book and they get in touch with with robert rhimes um and you know they all team up and in 75 rhines takes another extraordinary photo um which again if you know anything about the last month you'll recognize it's a kind of yellowish photo and it seems to show a head on a long neck attached to a kind of body uh again it requires a certain deep of faith, but once you've seen it, if you're looking for it, that's what you see. And this encourages Scott to propose that the Loch Ness Monster actually exists. And he comes up with a scientific name for it. And he wants to use the
早在70年代初，他还是个学生，后来他变成了一个狂热的“尼斯湖水怪疯狂追踪者”，并为此写了一本书。于是斯科特和邓斯代尔读了尼古拉斯·维切尔的书，他们联系了罗伯特·莱恩斯，你知道的，他们联合在了一起。在75年，莱恩斯拍下了又一张非凡的照片，如果你对上个月的事情有所了解，你会认出那是一张泛黄的照片，它似乎显示了一个连着某种身体的、长着长脖子的头部。同样，这需要一定程度的信念，但一旦你见过它，如果你在寻找它，这就是你所看到的。这鼓励了斯科特提出尼斯湖水怪确实存在的观点。他为它想出了一个学名，他想用
Loch Ness Monster as an icon for conservation. So in other words, if there is this prehistoric creature that is in the loch, log then it shows the you know it reveals the wonders of the natural world in a way that would sir you know enable the monster to serve as an absolute kind of ambassador for global conservation so that's what that's what he's um he's interested in he summons people from uh across the the scientific natural, the world of natural history and makes his case. And the response of the former chairman of the Natural History Museum's trustees is to say, we cannot do this without a specimen.
尼斯湖水怪作为保护自然环境的标志。换句话说，如果湖里真的有这样一种史前生物，那就表明（你知道的）它以一种能够让水怪充当全球自然保护绝对大使的方式，展现了自然世界的奇妙。所以这就是他感兴趣的地方。他召集了来自自然历史、自然科学世界各地的人，并阐述了他的观点。自然历史博物馆前受托人主席的反应是：没有标本，我们做不到这一切。
You know, we need a physical specimen. And without that, the chairman says, the monster not merely beggars description, but buggers it. And the response of of david attenborough who is a good friend of peter scott keen conservationist scott would like attenborough on board david attenborough's response is to say it's very courageous yeah um paleontologists say we we can't do anything about this without bones. And basically people don't accept that Peter Scott has a leg to stand on with this. And for Peter Scott's reputation, I think it's a bit like Hugh Trevor Roper and the Hitler Diaries.
你知道，我们需要一个实物标本。主席说，没有这个标本，水怪不仅令人难以形容，简直是糟透了。而戴夫·阿滕伯勒（David Attenborough）的反应是——他是彼得·斯科特的好友，也是坚定的环保主义者，斯科特希望阿滕伯勒加入——戴夫·阿滕伯勒的反应是，这非常勇敢。古生物学家则表示，没有骨头，我们对此无能为力。基本上，大家都不认为彼得·斯科特在这件事上站得住脚。对于彼得·斯科特的声誉来说，我认为这有点像休·特雷弗-罗珀（Hugh Trevor Roper）和希特勒日记事件。
It's, you know, it's a man with an incredibly distinguished reputation using that reputation to try and convince people that something so extraordinary as to seem incredible actually is true but it does turn out to be incredible and it uh it kind of really damages Scott's reputation in the way that Hugh Trevor Roper's reputation was damaged by his authenticating the Hitler diaries. So what's interesting about this, Tom, is that the story of the Loch Ness Monster as a historical phenomenon turns out not to be really a story about the Loch Ness Monster so much as it's a story about, well, it is a story about Scotland and its place in the
你知道，这是一个拥有极其显赫声誉的人，却利用这种声誉去试图说服人们，相信如此非凡、看似不可思议的事情竟然是真的。但事实证明这确实不可思议，而且它在某种程度上严重损害了斯科特的声誉，就像休·特雷弗-罗珀因为鉴别希特勒日记真伪而名誉受损一样。所以，汤姆，有趣的是，尼斯湖水怪作为一种历史现象的故事，结果证明它其实并不是一个关于尼斯湖水怪的故事，而是一个关于苏格兰及其在
imagination as a sort of wild, as the Highlands as a kind of wild part of the United Kingdom. But it's also really, am I pushing it too far to say it's a story about the aftermath of the Victorian kind of, in inverted commas, conquest of the natural world and of imperialism? Yeah. And what do the next generation do? What do people like, what's his name? What's his name? Marmaduke Wether like what's his name that mom what's in marmaduke wetherill or whatever his name is yeah um or or or peter scott people who are living in the shadow
人们想象中的地位的故事，它被视为一种荒野，高地被视为联合王国中某种荒野地区。但这真的也是——我是不是把它推得太远了——一个关于维多利亚时代对自然世界的所谓“征服”以及帝国主义余波的故事？是的。那下一代人会做什么呢？像什么名字的人？他叫什么名字？马马杜克·韦瑟利（Marmaduke Wetherill）或者管他叫什么名字的人，是的，或者彼得·斯科特，那些生活在阴影中的人
yeah and the duke of edinburgh as well i mean it's all that kind of it's it's that class of person who are coming of age in the 30s the 40s the 50s who have been raised by the traditions and the stories told of the British Empire to assume that their destiny is to go out and discover distant lands, strange valleys, rocky plateaus with dinosaurs on them, all that kind of stuff, that mythology of imperialism. And it's all gone and in a way the loch ness monster is a kind of a ghostly after echo of that and i think that that's why you get all these kind of figures uh marmaduke wetherall uh peter scott who are almost like figures out of time
是的，还有爱丁堡公爵，我是说所有这类人，那些在30年代、40年代、50年代成年，在英国大英帝国的传统和故事的熏陶下长大的人，他们认为自己的命运就是去发现遥远的土地、奇怪的山谷、长着恐龙的岩石高原，所有这些帝国主义的神话。这一切都消失了。在某种程度上，尼斯湖水怪就像是那种神话的幽灵般的回音。我认为这就是为什么你会看到所有这些人物——马马杜克·韦瑟利、彼得·斯科特——他们几乎就像是超越了时代的人物。
yeah and i but but i think it's not just about imperialism. I think it is also about a growing anxiety about the depletion of the natural world, about the collapse of biodiversity. I mean, people wouldn't have put it like that in the 50s. But Peter Scott was an absolutely committed conservationist and i think that he was on to something with this idea that the loch ness monster might be an icon because in a way our yearning to believe that the loch ness monster
是的，但我认为这不仅关于帝国主义。我认为这也是人们对自然世界日渐枯竭、生物多样性崩溃的日益焦虑。我的意思是，在50年代人们不会这样表达。但彼得·斯科特是一位绝对坚定的环保主义者，我认为他提出尼斯湖水怪可以作为一个标志这个想法是切中要害的，因为在某种程度上，我们渴望相信尼斯湖水怪
exists our yearning to believe that um a plesiosaur might have survived extinction is expressive of our longing to believe that you know huge numbers of species can survive extinction yeah you know it's there are more recent creatures where you know so the thylacine which is a um marsupial creature in tasmania that was wiped out um people again and again and again report seeing it in in in tasmania it always turns out not to be the case but again it kind of speaks almost of a kind of guilt i think yeah and it's interesting that um the loch ness monster coincides within 20 or 30 years with both yeti and bigfoot so bigfoot um in america um so as you said it's the pacific northwest i think it's a really a 1950s 60s kind of phenomenon and
存在的渴望——我们渴望相信蛇颈龙可能在灭绝中幸存下来——表达了我们对“大量物种能够在大灭绝中幸存”这一说法的渴望。是的，你知道的，还有一些更近期的生物，比如塔斯马尼亚的袋狼（thylacine），这是一种有袋类动物，已经被灭绝了。人们一次又一次地报告说在塔斯马尼亚看到了它，结果总是证明并非如此。但这也同样在某种程度上诉说了某种负罪感，我认为是的。有趣的是，尼斯湖水怪在二三十年内与雪人和大脚怪同时出现。所以大脚怪在美国，就像你说的，在太平洋西北地区，我认为这真的是一个50年代、60年代左右的现象，而且
again i wonder if it's the same you know the united states is being opened up by eisenhower's you know highways um by air travel and so on and people want to believe that there's a bit of the wilderness left and whether that's guilt or whether it's romanticism or exoticism i mean who can say um so you don't believe in the response to tom what a shame what a disappointment well i think it's i think it's pretty it's it's conclusively been proved not to exist because um what's happened of course in recent years is you've got dna that basically torpedoes all kinds of fantasies and dreams um and they they did um a study of the dna in loch ness and there is nothing unusual at all in the genetic material so you know if if there was a
再次让我好奇的是，这是否是同一回事。你知道，美国正在被艾森豪威尔的公路网、航空旅行等等所开拓，人们希望相信荒野还留存着一部分，无论是出于内疚、浪漫主义还是异国情调，谁说得准呢？所以，你不相信汤姆的回应？真遗憾，真让人失望。好吧，我认为这已经被确凿地证明是不存在的了，因为近年来发生的事情是，你有了DNA，它基本上粉碎了各种幻想和梦想。他们对尼斯湖的DNA进行了研究，其遗传物质中绝对没有任何异常之处，所以你知道，如果曾经有过一个
loch ness monster it's not there now so so that's very sad top party pooper tom holland but just just you know we talked about the scott Scottish tourist industry. Just one shout out for the Scottish tourist industry. Because have you been to Loch Ness? I've never been to Loch Ness, Tom. Okay. Well, it's great. I mean, it's really worth it. If you've had any interest in Loch Ness Monster, to go there, to look at the castle, it's all very familiar.
尼斯湖水怪，它现在已经不在那里了。所以这真是令人悲伤，扫兴的汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）。不过，我们刚刚谈到了苏格兰旅游业。让我们为苏格兰旅游业点个赞吧。因为你去过尼斯湖吗？我从来没去过尼斯湖，汤姆。好吧。这真的很棒。我的意思是，这真的值得一去。如果你对尼斯湖水怪有任何兴趣，去那里看看城堡，这一切都非常熟悉。
But they have a magnificent museum devoted to it. And you go around all this museum and the final room, it's saying, what was it? And I was fully expecting them to say it was a plesiosaur or something, or we don't know. And they say it was a sturgeon.
但他们有一个专门为它建造的宏伟博物馆。你参观了整个博物馆，到了最后一个展厅，上面写着：它是什么？我本以为他们会说它是一只蛇颈龙之类的，或者我们不知道。结果他们说它是一条鲟鱼。
That's, I thought that's really admirable that you've got this massive cash cow that tourists come all over the world. You basically say you've been, you know, no, it doesn't exist. So kudos to whoever runs that museum.
我觉得这真的很令人钦佩，你拥有这样一个巨大的摇钱树，世界各地的游客都会慕名而来，而你基本上告诉大家它并不存在。所以，向运营那个博物馆的人致敬。
Okay. I think we've put that one to bed as well. Don't you Tom? And on that bombshell, we will say goodbye and we will see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. bye bye bye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history
好吧。我想我们也已经把这事给抛诸脑后了。难道不是吗，汤姆？带着这个重磅消息，我们要说再见了，我们下期见。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。
for bonus episodes early access ad free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod dot com
想要收听独家加更节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。
that's rest is history pod dot com sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
即 restishistorypod.com。请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦花絮，在我们的问答环节中，我们将为你揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的优先购买权，请前往……该剧集目前尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。